e
the house will come to order chair
recognize the member from Auburn
representative Osborne who moves the
house adour from the session of February
20th 2025 you ready for the question all
those in favor say I those oppos n the
eyes haveit in the house is adjourned
the house will attend to a Prayer by
chaplain Reverend Jonathan Hopkins
conquer
morning let us
pray dear God we give you thanks for
this country we live in for this sweet
land of liberty this land where our
fathers died land of our Pilgrims Pride
help us to treasure this great country
and land let us never Tire of Defending
freedom and liberty let us be worthy of
those who have gone before and fought to
create and preserve our country help the
New Hampshire House of Representatives
to be inspired by this land of noble
free the woods and templed Hills this
land that was made for you and me this
land of Great Lakes soaring Mountain
tops help us to protect the natural
beauty of our state help us to Welcome
All Those Who come here dreaming of
freedom and liberty all those dreaming
to make a better life for their families
B Us Together As Americans who love the
land our country and each other we
continue to pray for representative
Grossman's son Oscar and to pray for
Shannon Gerard and their family as They
Mourn the death of her husband
Christopher even as we disagree about
policy let us never Tire of caring for
one another God Bless America this land
that we love stand beside her guide her
and light her from above stand with all
your people this day and celebrating all
the freedoms we enjoy and help us to
remember always that freedom is never
free but takes every citizen to do their
part to be vigilant in defense of these
amen chair recognizes a member from
antrum representative James kraton who
to of the United States of America to
the stand
Nation
indivisible andice for
all the chair recognizes Addison cutter
of antrum who will now sing our national
anthem
dawn
light what so
proudly
we at the
Twilight last
par
fight or the ramp part we
watch were so
gantly
[Music]
Rock the
bursting in
air
G through the
night that a flag was still
there oh
say that star
spangled
B
wave for the and of the
[Applause]
[Music]
the bre
[Applause]
the house will attend to request for Le
of
absence Mr Speaker the day illness
Representatives fra FR selig and trip
the day important business
Representatives comto DD pulin Michael
Murphy patricko stclair and turot the
day illness in the family representative
grman pleas Le of ab shall be granted
onless otherwise order by the house also
will attend to the introduction of
guests Mr Speaker please welcome John
Jud student from Holy Family Academy in
Manchester and Jenna Bailey student from
the academy for Science and design in
NASA are Pages for the
[Applause]
Mr Speaker please welcome Jacob Jameson
and Erica cutter parents and brother of
the singer guests of Representative
walner Steve Pierce former state
representative from Massachusetts Bill
and Sharon Palmer and wal Walter heing
guests of Representative Grant Anthony
Henry and Tyler witll guests of
Representative tibo William Clark and
Heather Morton of ncsl guests of
Representative Simpson and the speaker
the house will now attend to revenue
estimates hr17 which is located in your
seat Pockets representative Jian moves
ought to
thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker house resolution 17
is the culmination of many hours of
diligent work by the house Ways and
Means Committee and I thank them for
their for their help and up here with me
is representative Aly the ranking member
of the Democrats
the committee's charter that is the ways
and means considers
considering uh considers what the
unrestricted Revenue estimat should be
for fiscal years 2025 which we are
almost done with another three months or
so fiscal year 26 and 27 the conclusions
are summarized in hr17 I think most of
you or all of you should have it in your
seat Pockets um keep in mind that these
estimates are based on current law only
it doesn't doesn't matter what bills are
currently coming through the house um we
only consider what is current law at the
moment the committee started off the
process by hearing testimony from State
agencies such as the Department of
Revenue the office of the legislative
budget assistant the state treasurer the
Department of Business and economic
Affairs the Department of Employment
Security a senior demographer for UNH
and the UNH Casey School of Public
Policy we we try to get as much
background uh information as we can on
the economics of what's happening and
the committee also heard from economists
and others from outside the state
government such as the senior VP of
strategic planning and research at the
federal Home Loan Bank of Boston the CEO
and VP of the business and industry
Association The Association of Realtors
the New Hampshire fiscal policy
Institute and the Josiah Bartlett Center
for Public Policy all this initial
information gathering was to understand
the state of the economy and the
Direction it's headed over the next two
years we still don't have our crystal
ball so we use this as our best way of
estimating what's going to happen next
we heard from Individual state agencies
regarding where they expected um their
fiscal year 25 26 and 27 Revenue to end
up the committee heard presentations of
Revenue projections from the Department
of Revenue Department of administrative
Services the treasury Department the
Bureau of securi regulations judicial
Bland
the insurance department the Lottery
Commission and the Liquor Commission and
the Department of Transportation and
fish and game so as you can see we've
kind of panned uh span through the whole
uh of these agencies to understand where
do they think their estimates their high
and low estimates are going to come we
ask these agencies for those highs and
lows for fiscal year 25 26 and 27 the
committee then studied and considered
those estimates in concert with the
economic briefings
listen to as well as our own economic
information we've heard on news reports
and newspapers we've read ultimately the
revenue estimates that are summarized
before you are the culmination of the
work of the committee as it puts forth
its best estimates for state revenue and
its most honest
estimates t uh trying to kick aside any
political leanings just what is the
reality of the estimates and that's how
uh I would say we ended up with a uh
complete uh committee vote of I believe
it was was 19 to zero completely
bipartisan both Republicans and
Democrats agreeing this was a fair
estimate okay with that introduction let
me go to the to the green sheet that you
all have in front of you and quickly uh
not to spend much more time on this
because I know we have a lot of business
to get to but if we look at the uh line
12 business taxes uh business taxes we
have I think many of you probably
already know uh collections are down so
the that's why you'll see the official
estim
from before of 1.25 n million is higher
than the committee estimate for the rest
of 2025 we did see growth uh we did plan
on growth of 3 to 4% over the next two
years that that being fiscal year 26 and
and then another 3 or 4% fiscal year 27
and thus that's why if you look at the
rightand most uh roow there it's
1.102 uh actually billion I don't know
if I said million before um rooms and
meals are doing pretty good those are
those uh have have stood the test of
time pretty well that's why you see
those going up uh the tobacco tax we've
seen some degradation there primarily
because less people are smoking and more
people are starting to go towards
ecigarettes uh Vapors and and and the
liquids that uh go in them the taxes on
those aren't as high but the committee
also heard testimony that there may be
several establishments that that are not
paying their taxes uh on on those e
ecigarette things so um we need to look
at that further but for now tobacco
revenue is down mainly because uh
regular cigarette smoking is down liquor
sales also um are down and some of that
uh could be due to the same sort of
thing where ecigarettes and Vapes are
taking some of that so we need a we're
going to have to take a closer look at
where that's heading interest in
dividends tax you all should know um by
now that that's going away that's why
when you look at column 16 you see the
that going down and then ultimately zero
uh in
2027 um and then you've got uh things
like insurance tax Communications uh
Services tax that are pretty stable
those don't vary much from year to year
uh the real estate transfer tax uh
obviously just a lack of in inventory
has caused real estate uh sales uh to
diminish but prices are higher the net
effect is we've seen a little
degradation but we're also starting to
see an uptick in real estate purchase
again so that's why you'll see those
numbers going up in 26 and 27 and then
things like court fines and fees on line
20 uh line 21 Securities revenues beer
tax 22 all those are very stable don't
vary a whole lot um line 23 other that's
uh typically interest on on cash
Holdings there was a lot of money from
covid that was earning interest um and
that's as that slowly goes away you see
a decrease there and then um as you look
through the through the rest of the um
Lottery uh Lottery is down a little bit
but we expect that to stay fairly stable
uh tobacco settlement is basically
there's a tobacco settlement that uh
over the next we're still another 10
years or so where we'll be collecting
that that's that's fairly stable line 26
utility property tax uh pretty uh that
is pretty stable Statewide property tax
the rest of the sheet going on down is
fairly stable not a whole lot of change
so um this is uh the committee did their
best uh estimates uh we spent a lot of
time trying to come to the reality of
what it really is and that's why I think
it was unanimous vote and this is where
we ended up I ask for your uh press the
green button to pass this
you the the question is on the motion to
Auto
pass are you ready for the question all
those in favor say i i n the eyes have
it the motion is adopted the Jian moves
at H R 17 be laid on the table the
question is on the motion to lay hr17 on
the table are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppose
nay the eyes have it and hr17 is laid on
the table the house will now attend for
Mr Speaker from the committee on
resources Recreation and development
House Bill 691 removed by
Representatives plov Granger Tom Manion
delus Dunn Wei Hall Perez sodi and
Penza are there any other bills
removement consent calendar
representative Osman moves at the
consent calendar with the relevant
amendments as printed in today's house
record be adopted are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I those
oppose nay the eyes have it ENT calendar
is adopted the rules of the house from
the committee on environment and
agriculture hb1 153 FN HB 215 FN and HB
566 FN are referred to the committee on
finance the committee on the municipal
and County government HB 547 FN is
referred to the committee on finance
she
majority the committee on ways and means
to which was referred House Bill 503 FN
an act amending how revenues from taxes
are allocated to the education trust
fund consider the same report the same
with the following resolution that is
inexpedient to late present seal or for
the majority of the
committee minority elect committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the recommendation at the bill ought to
pass representative Thomas shamber for
the minority of the committee the chair
Simpson thank you Mr
Speaker we need to acknowledge that tax
cuts for the wealthy and multinational
corporations have left our local
property taxpayers footing the bill for
Vital services for granite Staters we're
now seeing a budget that pushes costs
onto Working Families including a 5% tax
on Working Families for health care
which they can't afford we need to have
a conversation about how we help working
and middle class Granite State families
in this state but this isn't the bill I
503 the mo motion before us is
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
question division do you want a division
you want a
division this will be a division vote
yeah swe asked for represented Sweeney
has asked for a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
seat the motion before us
is in expedient to legislate on House
Bill 503 FN this is a roll call vote
chair recognize representative shanberg
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that the present New Hampshire tax
policies are cutting needed revenues
while downshifting costs onto the backs
of towns cities and our neighbors in our
districts and if I know that this unfair
tax system which is rigged for the
multinational corporations and the ultra
rich could be changed by adding over
$700 million to the state coffers by
2027 for property tax relief would I now
push the red button for our neighbors to
have a fair and balanced tax
system chair recognize represent genian
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill would increase
the business profits tax the business
Enterprise tax the meals and rentals tax
and bring back the interest and
dividends tax and if I also know that
increasing all these taxes will hurt New
Hampshire businesses and New Hampshire
consumers and if I also know that this
bill came out with a strong bipartisan
vote of 16 to3 for itl would I now press
the green button thank you the motion
before us is inexpedient to legislate
andh House Bill 53 FN it's a roll call
vote if you're in
favor you press the green button if of
your oppos you'll press the red button
what
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
vote 345 voting a 27 voting
passed committee on ways and means to
which was referred House Bill 591 FN
enact expanding hours for Kino gambling
on weekends having considered the same
report the same of the recommend the
bill ought to pass s of Mary Ford for
the committee are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those suppose nay the eyes have it and
adopted I'm going I I'll let him do this
one
go the majority of the committee on ways
and means to which was referred House
Bill 596 FN an act relative to reporting
requirements for entities entities that
collect meals and rooms taxes having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
it is inexpedient to legislate
representative serel oros for the
majority of the committee the minority
of the committee having considered the
same and being unable to agree with the
majority Report with the following
Amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with Amendment
representative Susan Aly for the
committee the questions on the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislator you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those
oose nay the eyes have it and the
adopted the committee on children and
family law to which was referred House
Bill 187 FN an act relative to
restraining orders sought by a parent on
behalf of a minor child having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass representative Cassandra LC for
the committee the questions on the
majority committee report of o pass are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say I I all those oppos nay the
adopted
Finance House Bill 187 is referred to
the committee on finance all
right we have majority committee
Amendment then we have the amendment
the majority of the committee on
criminal justice and Public Safety which
was referred as Bill 143 an act relative
to the issuance of no trespass orders on
municipal or School District property
having considered the same report the
same with the following amendments and
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass with Amendment representative
Jennifer rhs for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the following resolution resolved
that it is inexpedient to legislate
representative David Muse for the
minority of the
committee the majority committee
amendment is
0408 H printed on house record 14 on
pages 44 and 45 the questions on the
amendment are you ready for the question
no all those in favor say I I all those
in favor
nay the eyes have it and the amendment
is
adopted bill on second reading open the
bill is on second reading and open a
further Amendment representative Muse
offers Amendment
Pockets representative Ro is recognize
amendment thank you Mr Speaker Mr
Speaker the the amendment um is is a
bipartisan from the committee it just
cleans up a couple questions on this
it makes it so that um when a no
trespass order is
issued they do not have to wait until
the next meeting scheduled to address an
appeal of that and it also makes it so a
super majority is not needed to consider
the not trest just a simple majority and
that works both ways so it's just a
all the question is on the adoption of a
Amendment
0774 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I all those oppos
adopted question now is on the main
Amendment a division's been requested
all right the questions on the main
motion of oop pass is amended on House
Bill 143 this is a division vote if you
are in favor press the green button
oppose press the red voting state are
represent
McFarland
alone
represent have all members present had
an opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 368 in the affirmative four in the
the majority of the committee on
criminal justice and Public Safety to
which was referred House Bill 245 FN an
act establishing the speed enforcement
and awareness fund and providing grants
to Municipal law enforcement for Speed
enforcement and speed awareness traffic
equipment having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
saorin D Shaner hopefully I got that
right for the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee on
criminal justice and Public Safety
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass representative Buzz sherff
for the minority of the
committee representative Shar is
recognized to speak against the
committee report
thank you Mr Speaker uh I'll be brief I
speak as much as a uh a police
commissioner uh in Port smouth as I do
as a representative those of you who've
been police officers know that uh
speeding is the largest number of
complaints to any Police Department in
the State uh particularly speeding in
residential areas one of the most
valuable things at starting to reduce
that if not ever getting rid of it is
those digital signs that say slow down
or you're going 45 in a 30 um and
there's a a variety of equipment uh that
helps moderate the the excess of
speeding that's going on um you it's the
department of safety is not in fact
allocating a lot of funds to do that
even though they could uh and to uh to
pass this bill it would not in it would
not require a lot of bureaucracy so I
urge uh everyone to press the red button
and vote
no representative Rose is recognized to
speak in support of the committee
report thank you Mr
Speaker colleagues you know what else
will help alleviate speeding your right
foot and looking at your
speedometer that works I guarantee it
now one thing that I will tell you is I
am not an expert in New Hampshire
history but fortunately for me I know
who to call I have a colleague that is a
selectman and I'm fortunate enough to uh
share a town with him two towns that I
represent he's my own little personal
Cliff claven so I called him and I said
hey I have a question if a town needs to
get some
money are they able to go to the state
or are the grants for highway equipment
you know slow down little blinking signs
and he's said nope there's not but let
me tell you why there's
not apparently about 30 years ago don't
quote me on that cuz I am not Cliff
claven we still had some justice of the
peace magistrates in the state and their
job whenever money came in from a ticket
was to decide how much that money was
and it stayed in that town and they said
oh look this is a little bit of conflict
ADV interest interest it's called
policing for profit
so if we adopt this we're going back to
incentivize to give tickets to buy stuff
the police do sit alongside the roads
and they do give tickets because I can
assure you I talk to them
often so let's not go
backwards the system is working just
Speaker the question on the majority
committee report of inexpedient
legislate who requested a roll call
Representative Barry requests a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded it is
this will be a roll call vote members
clear the question is on the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate representative Harry gther
recognized for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill will assist our
law enforcement with what they need and
give them the tools that will help on
the highways and the byways in New
Hampshire I would press the red button
so another motion can be made thank
you representative Roy recognized for
parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I don't want our
police departments to become fundraising
arms of our cities and towns and if I
know that no Police Department asked for
this bill would I vote green to support
the committee's ital thank
you the questions on the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislative on House Bill 245 this is a
roll call vote if you are in favor press
the green button oppose press the red
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 225 and the affirmative 147 and the
the majority of the committee on
criminal justice and Public Safety to
which is referred House Bill 64 FN an
act relative to the transparency of
federal agency operations within New
Hampshire having considered the same
report the same with the recommendation
at the bill of to pass representative
Sabor D shanier for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the following resolution resolved
that it is inexpedient to legislate
representative Ray Newman for the
minority of the
committee representative Newman is
recognized to speak against the
committee
report thank you Mr
Speaker this bill requires the Attorney
General to formally request that federal
government agencies with law enforcement
investigatory or operational activities
in New Hampshire
voluntarily provide aggregated an an
anim
anatomized data
quarterly according to testimony these
requests would require federal agencies
to report
voluntarily 10 data points like the
number of facilities and staff in the
state warrants serve
and arrest and deportations
accomplished producing this data will be
very work intensive and costly a costly
task for those
agencies it will also be costly to New
Hampshire the fiscal note says that the
bill will require three new staff
members at a cost of over $200,000 in
the first year and in future years and a
new website will be required to report
these results
since the provision of the information
is strictly voluntary cooperations by
questionable due to the downsizing of
federal agencies and the fact that some
of the data may not be collected or
reported by these
agency if this bill were to become law
and the federal agencies do not
cooperate the Attorney General will
still have to build and maintain a
searchable website hire staff and
continue to make quarterly requests and
reports
and just an indication of some of the
problems with being asked by this um
Bill the federal a one of the things the
website is required to indicate is the
federal agencies not present or
operational in New Hampshire now think
about how many agencies there are that
would be on the list that would have to
be
updated the production of this
information on all federal agencies
totally absent from New Hampshire seem
to be an almost unworkable task to
maintain an update given the fact given
these facts the bill should be deemed
inexpedient to legislate until it
becomes less costly and more
efficient thank you Mr
Speaker representative Roy recognized
speak and support of the committee
report thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
the committee heard the same testimony
and we came to the conclusion that the
citizens in Hampshire have a right to
know what their federal government is
doing in our state and if they refuse to
answer then that website will say your
federal government refus to answer and
the citizens can take that to the
federal government but our citizens have
a right to know who's being arrested
who's homes are being searched who's
being disappeared things of that nature
um so if you are like the rest of the
committee would like to know what's
going on um and you'd like our attorney
general to ask the federal government
what they're doing vote Yes and support
the committee thank
you the questions on the majority
committee report of ought to pass divis
a division votes been requested members
clear
the questions on the majority committee
report about to pass on House Bill
640 representative Muse is recognized
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know this bill would require
federal agencies to voluntarily provide
data that they have no obligation to
supply at a time when the federal
Workforce is being challenged to be more
efficient with fewer people and if I
also know the fiscal says that to comply
with this bill the Attorney General's
office would be forced to staff three
new positions at a cost of close to 3/4
of a million dollars over the next three
years when we have our own budget and
efficiency
challenges and finally Mr Speaker if I
know that there are ways to improve
transparency that may not involve making
a large investment to post hard to
collect information on a website that
where most people can never find what
they're looking for anyway then would I
press the red button to defeat this
motion so another motion may be made
thank
you representative Roy recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry Mr Speaker if I know that when
you ask someone to do a job and they
don't really want to do it they tell you
it's going to cost a lot more than it
really does because they don't want you
to take the job and if I know that and
if I know that this will not cost what
they're saying it's going to cost I
would I vote to support this so that we
could find out what's really happening
in our state thank
you the questions on the majority
committee report have ought to pass on
House Bill 640 on this is a division
vote if you're in favor press the green
button opposed press the red voting
[Music]
represent
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house legend of
the state of the
vote 187 in the affirmative 183 in the
negative the committee reports
adopted and it's going to
finance House Bill 640 is referred to of
finance theer for message chair
recognizes the clerk for Senate messages
Mr Speaker the Senate concurs with the
house in the passage of the following
entitled bill with amendment in the
passage of which amendment the Senate
asked the concurrence of the house house
bill 399 establishing a commission to
study the New Hampshire zoning enabling
act and relative to the effective date
program representative Alexander moves
at the house concurr and is recognized
to
speak thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
the uh Senate made two changes to this
bill first they moved out the uh
delegation Authority and gave it back to
the speaker's office to appoint in
consultation with the majority and
minority leaders and in addition the
effective date of the cpce bill that we
passed last week that was signed into
law happened to be I believe January 1st
2026 so this would update the effective
date of that law to immediately on
passage so that will happen hopefully
later this week so I ask the house to
concur thank
you the questions on the motion to
concur are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those
oppose nay no eyes have it and the
Motions
adopted the chair recognizes the clerk
Mr Speaker I have a message uh from the
chair of the committee on finance Mr
Speaker and Mr clerk I wish to wave off
House Bill 153 from the the committee on
environment and agriculture it
establishes a study committee and does
you the majority of the committee on
education funding to which is referred
House Bill
484 an act relative to reallocation or
repurposing of Career and Technical
education classrooms spaced by local
school districts having considered the
same report the same with the following
Amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with Amendment
representative Rick lad for the majority
of the committee the minority of the
committee having considered the same and
being unable to agree with the majority
Report with the following resolution
resolved that it is inexpedient to
legislate representative Tracy brei for
the minority of the
committee the amendment is
03588 printed in house record 14 on page
51 the questions on the amendment are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say I I any oppose nay the eyes
adopted now on to the main motion about
to pass as amended are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I any
oppose nay the eyes have it and the
adopted the majority of the committee on
education funding to which was refer
House Bill 5:15 an act repealing the
chartered Public School eligibility for
state school building Aid having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
it is inexpedient to legislate
representative Daniel papichi Muller for
the maor majority of the committee the
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass represent of Hope Damon for the
minority of the committee division votes
been requested this will be a division
look
the questions on the majority committee
report of inexpedient to legislate on
House Bill 515 representative crean is
Mr speaker thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that chat schools are
not required to follow the same statutes
as traditional public schools and if I
know that in the previous bium only
three of 17 Public School building
projects were
funded and if I know that the governor's
proposed budget has no funds for
building Aid beyond what the state is
already
obligated to what I now press the green
division maybe maybe you want to press
person what I now PR press the red
pass all right then we've all done it
representative lad's recognized for
parliamentary inquiry thank you very
much Mr Speaker if I know just eight
months ago HB 354 was signed in the law
authorizing building Aid eligibility for
Charter Public Schools that comply with
building standards
have state approved asset disposition
plans and that meet all required
renovation and construction requirements
in law and if I further believe this
attempt to undo Charter Public School
eligibility for building Aid support is
short cited and compromises the safety
security and well-being of New Hampshire
students who opt to attend a Charter
Public
School and lastly if you believe there
is no ration
reason to deny or discriminate against
any public school student from learning
in a safe and healthy learning
environment would you then join me in
rejecting this ill-conceived legislation
you the questions on the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislator on ask Bill 5:15 and this is
a division vote if you're in favor press
the green button oppose press the red
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 212 in the affirmative 159 and the
adopted the majority of the committee on
education funding which to which was
referred House Bill 583 FN local an act
relative to State participation in the
Medicaid direct certification program
for free and reduced price School meals
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that it is inexpedient to
legislate representative Daniel papovich
Miller for the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment representative d
committee for what reason does a member
rise Mr Speaker I move to lay HB 583 on
the table representative Osborne moves
to lay House Bill 583 on the table the
division's been requested this will be a
division vote members take your SE roll
call oh you want a roll call
okay and it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take
repres
all righty the motion is whether to lay
House Bill 583 on the table and this is
a roll call vote representative
spillsbury is recognized for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that HB 583 is less about
feeding kids at school than it is about
hopes to boost adequacy funding and
extraordinary needs grants at levels
that our developing budget can't
support if I also know that all students
currently eligible for free and reduced
meals can be registered today without
this
legislation finally Mr Speaker if I know
that the role of deciding whether to
register a child for the free and
reduced meals program belongs to the
parents who may have their own reasons
for not applying would I now press the
green button to support the table motion
thank you Mr Speaker representative
wheel was recognized for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that there is a bipartisan
committee amendment that is waiting to
be heard if we can overturn the itl
motion on this legislation and if I know
that the tabling motion on this
legislation would result in kids not
being fed despite what the members said
then would I now vote against the motion
to table so that at the very least we
could debate the itl motion and the
amendment that is before us thank you Mr
Speaker the question is whether to lay
House Bill 583 on the table and this is
a roll call vote if you're in favor
press the green button oppose press the
red voting stations are open for 30
seconds
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote that C attend of the
state of the
vote 196 in the affirmative 174 opposed
table the majority of the committee on
education funding to which is referred
House Bill 770 FN an act relative to
establishing a program to earn tuition
credits for State of New Hampshire
higher education institutions through
community service having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Raymond peoples for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass representative Wayne
Burton for the minority of the committee
representor Burton's recognized to speak
thank you very much Mr Speaker if passed
House Bill 770 FN will give high school
and college students a leg up on
covering their expenses at a usnh
institution or Community College through
earning Financial Credit to reduce the
amount of excuse me of loans they would
have to otherwise incur through engaging
in public
service with a total cost of a 4ar years
$154,000 we must help families pay that
bill without saddling the students with
excessive debt under this program
students could earn up to $2,500 a year
for 100 hours of work in a
nonprofit also participating in this
program they will gain professional
experience working in public service
organizations such as nursing homes food
banks or homeless
shelters studies show that students who
engage in public service while in school
improve their academic
performance contrary to what the
majority Report asserts with regard to
net costs the fiscal note indicates
otherwise predicting that the program
quote could attract more New Hampshire
Public High School grads to enroll in
usnh institutions which could grow
enrollment and net revenue the the
estimates of the cost of implementation
May well be covered by the additional
enrollment encouraged by the program and
the immeasurable benefit of retaining
native Granite Staters here the students
who developed suggested calling it a
triple win that is avoiding debt
encouraging public service and retaining
our college graduates in their home
state please read the please PR press
the red button so another vote can be
made
thank
you representative peoples is recognized
report thank you Mr
Speaker this bill would establish a
program for edible high school students
to earn credits through community
service that's a very lofty goal and I
would applaud anybody does community
service but the bigger problem is how to
how to establish that program the
database the overhead the people that we
need to maintain the records for all the
eligible uh jobs eligible um community
service that would be allowed to earn
credits for it also establishes a cost
on the highered institutions that they
would have to
bear I would ask you to support an itail
motion because of the ongoing costs and
our tight budget year right now this
isn't the right time for this program
all right the questions on the majority
committee report of in expedient to
legislate divisions been requested
go
[Music]
please I should not have representatives
in the
aisle representative Hill we're in the
okay the question is on the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 770 and this is
a division vote representative bricky is
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that given my
extensive background as a high school
educator and District administrator the
importance of a high school student
participating in public service and if I
know that this legislation will help
retain the best and the brightest of New
Hampshire's high school graduates which
is of great importance to the wealth of
the State of New
Hampshire and if I know that this bill
will help the public colleges and
universities in New Hampshire by
increasing enrollment filling them with
highly qualified candidates what I now
press the red button so a better motion
okay representative spillsbury is
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I concede that
encouraging more students to perform
community service projects would be good
and various ways of doing so exist but I
would rather ask them to volunteer than
to trade College tuition credits as an
inducement and if I have no way to know
that the what the net revenue effect uh
will be of the bill on the University
and Community College systems and
further if I know that the Department of
Education would require several new
full-time staff to qualify a myriad of
eligible
organizations sites and activities and
further create a system to track and
approve the activities of up to 12,500
High School seniors not to mention
underclassman would I re recognize the
overwhelming burden of this centralized
approach and press the green button to
support the majority motion of itl thank
you Mr
Speaker the question is on the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 770 this is a
division vote if you're in favor press
the green button opposed press the red
[Music]
McFarland
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote 206 in
the affirmative 162 in the negative the
the majority of the committee on
education funding to which was referred
House Bill 771 FN an act relative to
funding for open enrollment schools
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass representative Rick
lad for the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
David luno for the minority of the
committee representative Damon is
report thank you Mr
Speaker an open enrollment school is any
public school which accepts students
from other Public Schools outside the
district HB 771 would change how funding
for open enrollment schools is sent and
received it would require all public
school districts to establish a line
item in their operating budgets
reflecting expenditures for open
enrollment to send students to those
Public Schools outside their District HB
771 essentially mandates every school to
become a sending School the tuition
would be set at 80% of the average per
pupil cost for the sending students home
District the taxpayers of the Open
Enrollment receiving school and their
taxpayers would fund the difference
there is no statement in the bill
qualifying how many students a sending
District would be obligated to pay
tuition
for this bill requires local taxpayers
to subsidize students attending schools
in other districts a considerable risk
of mandating open enrollment schools is
a general decrease in the adequacy of
education for many students because of
our chronic systemic funding disparities
if as a state we fund funded public
education fairly there would probably be
little demand for open
enrollment for open enrollment to reduce
operating costs for the sending district
there would need to be a mass Exodus of
students from that District this is
unlikely so the overall costs of the
sending district will increase as the
cost of tuition students is added to the
existing operating costs do you hear the
chingching of increasing property taxes
I
do receiving District who are not fully
enrolled and can accommodate tuition
students which are many can only benefit
financially from receiving more
districts while the sending District
suffers
financially those receiving districts
can choose whether to enroll additional
students and which to enroll so this
bill gives them all the control and all
the
funds given the lack of Equitable school
funding across the state the minority
believes that house bill 771 will only
increase the strain on property
taxpayers widen the disparities between
communities and create further
opportunity gaps now between neighboring
school districts further before any
change to open enrollment statutes are
considered we should wait for the ruling
on a Case currently filed in the New
Hampshire Supreme Court related to open
enrollment schools the majority
respectfully requests your itl vote and
Mr Speaker I request a roll call
represent Lads recognized speak in
support of the committee
report thank you very much Mr
Speaker let's go back and review what we
have as far as open enrollment schools
in the state at presently this law went
in effect back in
2009 and I haven't seen a mass Exodus
from anybody regarding it what we have
here is we have a system where we can
have open enrollment within the school
district where one person goes from one
high school to another student a school
in the that District or we can have
students in another District outside the
residential district having their
students tuition to the open enrollment
District how these open enrollment
schools accept students is based upon
the local board making that decision on
the number of spots they have vacancies
they have open in their schools and it's
based upon aptitude achievement of the
student and other needs so it's just
clearly an open open enrollment we have
five extra chairs in this particular
program we have five open spots what
happens if there's more people applying
for those spots from out a district
while it's like the charter schools
where there's a lottery held this is all
in current law now why do we have this
bill coming forward here the
771 it
clarifies open enrollment the Open
Enrollment school is the receiving
School
not the sending School the sending
school does not have to have a local
legislative decision by their school
board or the town to decide we're an
open enrollment school because the kids
are going from the residential district
to the open enrollment School in the
other District or even between schools
within the district I experienced that
when I was up in Anchorage we had kids
going from West High to East High I'm
sure you have some of that going on in
Manchester as well
so we have a program we call the
Manifest education hardship that's a
program which is tuition if you have a
student not meeting the interest that
student in that school district and they
need help the parent can come and
request of that school district to have
the child placed due to this manifest
education hardship in another school
this quite frankly is not working well
at all we have very few of these that
are actually accepted or even approved
by the State Board of Education this
program right here is going to help us
attain these efficiencies to scale we
need in this state we've often times
talked about restructuring our saus we
have 107 saus some of the saus are right
beside each other and very small
districts why couldn't they share some
of the curriculum and instruction
between the two districts which some do
if I have school over a over here and
school B over here and school a does not
have a good science program but B does
why not have the student being able to
go into that open enrollment school over
there in B to get that chemistry class
which I can't offer in a it's logical so
what we're doing was we're going to be
able to share special education services
we're going to be able to go have the
student decide curriculum where that is
best for them the best fit it's going to
be a very coste effective program and it
elim it will eliminate duplication of
services where is this occurring right
now do we have any open enrollment
schools in the state right now yes we do
Prospect Mountain for example is one
alad and Barnstead have that and they
have a a leader down there administrator
who has been quoted saying I welcome any
New Hampshire family to evaluate our
strengths and weaknesses and decide for
themselves where their CH children can
be best served isn't that wonderful that
comes from an administrator in a school
district he's open to open enrollment
so what we have right now we've
clarified the Open Enrollment school and
the sending school that EXC which is the
receiving School the Open Enrollment
school is the sending School how does
the payment work 80% of the funds from
that sending School District go to the
open enrollment School the sending
District still carries the
responsibilities for special education
20% is Left Behind so in conclusion I
would ask you to support open enrollment
it's a p pathway for us to get
efficiency of scale in the state which
we drastically
need representative Granger has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded that is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
the questions on the majority committee
report about to pass on House Bill 771
and this is a roll call
vote representative Weinstein is
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
here if I know that this bill would
create a financial burden on the sending
districts and would who would be
required to pay 80% of their average per
pupil costs to receiving schools and if
I know that this bill creates a control
and benefit imbalance where receiving
districts have the power to choose
whether to enroll additional students
and would benefit financially from
increased
enrollment and if I know this would
drain resources from already underfunded
districts and exacerbate existing
educational inequalities and lastly if I
know that we are waiting for a ruling
from the New Hampshire Supreme Court
related to open enrollment schools then
would I now press the red button to
defeat this motion thank
you representative lad's recognized for
parliamentary inquiry thank you very
much Mr Speaker if I know this program
is coste effective and has the potential
to eliminate duplication of programming
in neighboring schools and school
districts
and lastly if I also know this program
offers Parents Choice while keeping
public dollars in public schools would I
then press the green
button the questions on the majority
committee report have ought to pass this
is a roll call vote if you're in favor
press the green button opposed press the
red voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house of of the
state of the
vote 205 in the affirmative 169 and
negative the committee report is adopted
House Bill 771 is referred to the
finance the majority of the committee on
education policy and administration to
which was referred House Bill 208 FN an
act relative to certification
requirements for School nurses having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment representative Glenn
cordelli for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the following resolution resolved
that it is inexpedient to legislate
representative Megan Murray for the
minority of the
committee the committee amendment is
0338 H printed on house record 14 on
pages 46 to 47 questions on the adoption
of the amendment you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I all
those oppose nay no the eyes have it and
the Amendments adopted now the main
motion ought to pass with Amendment
representative Murray's recognized to
colleagues though we can all agree that
nursing shortages within our schools is
a problem worthy of solving the majority
of nursing shortages in school settings
are not due to Bur some requirements
within the department of education's
certification requirements but are more
likely due to insufficient pay that
matches the level of work and care that
our nurses provide in school communities
day after day HB 208 as amended quite
simply removes all certification
requirements within the doe and solely
relies on a single associates degree
within the oplc removing continuing educ
excuse me continuing education towards a
bachelor's degree in nursing there are
many instances in which our nurses in
our school community Comm unities serve
in ways that are unique to school
settings where pediatric medical needs
exist at higher rates and students with
complex medical needs come into the
building daily there are a Litany of
unique circumstances that require School
nurses to be supported uh regarding the
needs of a building District staff and
the unique body of students in
attendance throughout the day
eliminating the entirety of the
additional nursing certification within
the doe increases legal liabilities to
schools and districts nurses have
countless other things that they are
tasked with on a daily basis
certifications around nursing and
special education impl implementation in
school settings are vital to ensuring
that the child um that the care of a
child is carefully collaborated with
providers Specialists parents and
teachers finally if we are to remove all
of the Department of Education
certification as it relates to school
nursing there are critical components to
nursing that could be
impacted such as school management case
DCF management health records management
infectious disease management and a
Litany of other things please vote no on
the motion of V to pass as amended so
another motion can be made and Mr
Speaker I humbly ask for a division
vote representative cordelli is
recognized speak in support of the
committee
report thank you Mr Speaker there are
two primary reasons for the passage of
this amended bill which eliminates the
need for the Department of Education
certification of School nurses reason
one
what does the Department of Education
know about
nursing and we have a board of nursing
to license
nurses let's eliminate one unnecessary
license and the cost how about the cost
to the applicant it currently cost uh an
applicant to get that certification $120
for a three-year certification and it's
going up to
$150 we have heard that districts need
need pediatric or specially trained
nurses the Department of Education is
not going to do that training you know
how they award
certifications they look at the
transcript they look at the work
experience and ask for the
money that's how they award
certifications and we think that maybe
local school districts are smart enough
to actually hire a nurse who has the uh
proper training in not a hospice
nurse reason
two licensing from the Department of
Education certification costs more to
the retirement cost to a school district
due to an obsolete uh
provision here are the numbers the
retirement system charges a district
135% of wages for a non-licensed
employee but for a doe certified
employee charges
19.6% and who gets that 6% differential
the retirement system not the employee
when they
retire So based on the number of nurses
in the system this could mean a savings
to school districts of over $1.6
million so let's add this up reason
number one elimination of unnecessary
licensing and less cost to appli against
a
win reason number two potential large
savings to local
districts a win so let's add up the
legislation it's a win-win solution
thank you vote
green representative Murray requested a
division vote this will be a division
seats representative Osborne requests a
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
Yep this there will be a roll call vote
C
the questions on the majority committee
report about to pass as amended on House
Bill
208 representative Cornell is recognized
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this bill as amended removes all of
the school nursing requirements already
within the Department of Education
statutes and if I know that a p
pediatric background really is a
necessity for a school nurse and if I
know that School nursing is a specialty
that requires skills and knowledge
Beyond basic nurses nursing for example
knowledge related to special education
plans would I now press the red button
so another motion can be
made representative Freeman's recognized
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker
colleagues if I know that currently as a
nation we are facing a critical shortage
of healthcare profession professionals
and if I further know that nurses are
very heavily licensed vetted and
credentials and cherish their lure it
would not jeopardize such and finally if
I know that our children are a precious
commodity and School nurses or potential
School nurses understand this and would
not put our children In Harm's Way or
jeopardize their hard- earned licensure
would I now press the green button to
pass this piece of Common Sense
legislation
the questions on the majority committee
report of op to pass as amended on House
Bill 208 this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor press the green button
oppos press the red voting stations are
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 211 in the affirmative 163 in the
for what reason does a member
rise thank you Mr Speaker I move that we
table HB 589 and I can speak to my
motion it's not before us that's that's
not before us have to wait till he reads
the report and it's okay and it's not a
Virginia who are these fine future
gallery Milford New Hampshire Welcome to
the New Hampshire
[Applause]
house any you want to try this out no
the majority of the committee on Fish
and Game and Marine Resources to which
was referred House Bill 589
FN an act defining and prohibiting want
and animal waste and prohibiting certain
Wildlife hunting contests having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
it is inexpedient to legislate
representative Paul Tudor for the
majority of the committee the minority
of the committee having considered the
same and being unable to agree with the
majority Report with the recommendation
that the bill Bill ought to pass
representative Lauren Fox for the
committee you're up Mr Speaker you
always seem to be in that chair when I
make a motion i' would like to move that
we table HB
589 the motion is in order the motion is
to lay House Bill 589 on the table are
division votes been requested members
take your seats representative would you
like Pi
the question is whether to lay House
Bill 589 on the
table representative Schultz is
recognized for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that
officials at fishing game administrative
and enforcement encourage the tabling of
this rather than killing it then I would
vote uh I would push the green button
thank
you Representatives we're in the voting
mode Mr
chair representative Spain's recognized
for parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that this
was a widely debated and listened to
bill in the committee and that even the
minority agreed that the way that it was
written was
unworkable but Mr Speaker if I know that
the minority also wanted to introduce an
amendment that was so radically
different that tabling this would not
make any difference because they could
still bring that Amendment as a new bill
next year so that tabling serves no
function and Mr Speaker if I know that
fish and game has already said that the
major portions that were the goal of
this bill were going to be handled in
rules and those rules are going in front
of the public this summer then Mr
Speaker would I vote no to table so that
we can get on with the itl thank you the
question is whether L House Bill 589 on
the table and this is a division vote if
you're in favor press the green button
oppos press the red voting stations are
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 167 in the affirmative 205 in the
negative motion fails the question is
now on the majority committee report of
inexpedient to legislate are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I I all those opposed
nay the eyes have it and the committee
the committee on Health Human Services
and elderly Affairs to which was
referred House Bill 54 FN an act
allowing alternative treatment centers
to operate for profit having considered
the same report the same with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative Dave Nagel for for
the committee representative Granger
requests a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded that is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
the questions on the majority committee
report about to pass and now spell 554
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor press the green button opposed
press the red voting stations are open
[Music]
Lane must have been nap time have all
members present had an opportunity to
vote the house will attended the state
of the vote 357 and the affirmative 14
and the negative the committee reports
adopt
what V 358
to4 sorry I guess it was 358 to 14
either way the committee reports
adopted it's to
fin House Bill 5 four is referred to the
the majority of the committee on Health
Human Services and elderly Affairs to
which is referred House Bill 94 FN an
act relative to coverage of circumcision
under the State Medicaid plan having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass representative Matt Drew from
the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the following resolution resolved
that it is inexpedient to legislate
representative Jessica ltin from the
minority of the
committee the bill is on second reading
and open to Amendment representative
Amendment thank you Mr
Speaker I'm going to say what I said a
year
ago in so far as that it will be a
surprise to absolutely no one who knows
me or even knows of me that I am a huge
vocal passionate supporter of socialized
medicine of healthare care as a human
right of Medicare for
all but much of the opposition to the
underlying bill here is the perception
that this is an attack on Medicaid an
attack on medical coverage for the
poorest of the poor for desperately
needed medical services so this
amendment makes the Medicaid question a
non-issue because it moves dollar for
dooll the savings that the department
will receive and not covering
non-therapeutic neonatal
circumcision to a vision screening a
pediatric vision screening program that
almost every other state has and that
has had broad support in this chamber
for several years so I want to talk
about why that moving that coverage from
one one procedure to another or to
another program is
appropriate non- therapeutic neonatal
circumcision is not considered medically
necessary by any medical organization in
the world including this country
including this state no medical
organization in the world considers it
medically
necessary and that you understand that
right because 80% of the world is not
circumcised by default and we don't
circumcise any male mammal we don't
circumcise horses dogs cats sheep goats
and none of them seem to have widespread
problems in fact only one in 11,000
adult intact men have a need for a
circumcision later in
life some in this country some medical
organizations consider neonatal non-
therapeutic circumcision a preventative
measure but while only 1 in 11,000 in
Tech men need circumcision later in life
one in 20 people people will need an
appendectomy one and seven will need
their tonsils out we do not remove the
appendixes of infants because they might
need that surgery later we do not remove
the tonsils of infants we don't remove
any healthy tissue from an infant
because they might have an infection
life on the other hand one in six
circumcised infants experience pain and
excessive bleeding one in 20 experience
a serious infection and many thousands
experience like the cause of this bill
going in last year lifelong debilitating
conditions such as urinary
problems uh recurring infections
disfigurement and sexual
dysfunction and in this country where
1.4 million male babies are
circumcised uh about a hundred little
boys one day old
infants end up dying from complications
because of a
circumcision so while those
organizations may say there are some we
think maybe benefits and perhaps the
benefits might outweigh the risks I
would uh encourage people to ask the
parents of those hundred baby boys who
died whether the benefits outway the
risk or ask the adult men who have
permanent disfigurement and dysfunction
whether the benefits outweigh the
risk it is the only non-reconstructive
non- therapeutic cosmetic procedure that
we cover with taxpayer
dollars and I know that culturally it's
hard to move past the things that we've
always considered to be
normal the expectation that we know how
to predict the world helps us feel in
control of a world that is not
controllable but think of this the exact
analogous procedure in a female child
the removal of the clitoral hood is not
paid for by taxpayer dollars is not
covered under any kind of insurance it's
actually illegal you will be sent to
prison because on a logical level be
when we get Beyond what's comfortable
and normal and culturally acceptable on
a logical level we know that the genital
cutting of a tiny baby infant one day
old or a few hours old is wrong we know
that so I although I I passionately
support single-payer health care I don't
support this coverage any more than I
would support any other cosmetic
procedure on an eight-hour old infant or
anymore that I would support any
procedure that could harm a
baby surgery on a tiny piece of healthy
flesh for no other reason than cultural
expectation
however I hope while it may be
controversial whether there's medical
benefits to it or not I hope it's not
controversial that vision is a
legitimate
medical uh Health
Care in fact all those organizations
that don't think that non- therapeutic
neonatal circumcision is medically
necessary they think that Vision Care is
uh legitimate health care so this
amendment moves those savings dollar for
dooll into a pediatric vision screening
program which has been before this house
U multiple times which Most states have
the vast majority of states have a
Medicaid paid for Pediatric vision
screening program because
children don't know that their Visions
messed up because it's the only Vision
they ever had so they don't realize that
not seeing the Blackboard or the the
screen is not normal and so they don't
problems as I said Most states have this
this is exper the same exact language in
this amendment is the bill from the last
term it was retained in 23 it was
interim studied in 24 DHHS was fine with
it they said that the uh money was
fairly small it turns out miraculously
about the same amount that they will
save from circumcision which is about
$100,000 or less my side of the chamber
was unanimously in support of this
vision screening program the last two
years the other side was split but there
was broad support
so passing this amendment will remove
the question of whether or not it's
about Medicaid and attacking social
services and attacking health care for
the poor and make it purely about what
the underlying bill is about
amendment the questions on the adoption
of floor Amendment 0786 H are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I I all those oppose nay no
fails now on to the main motion of a to
pass representative Nagel is recognized
report thank you Mr chairman um I'd like
to begin by thanking all the people that
were involved in this discussion um
multiple stakeholders over hours and
hours was both in session and Beyond and
it was really interesting and made me
think a lot and and um that's an
important thing there in lies the actual
problem with this bill this is an
incredibly complex issue and that's why
I can't support the autop pass motion
basically what it does is reduces a very
complex bioc psychosocial issue to a
purely biomedical one that's overly
reductionist non-patient centered
thinking which is a trend that we're
trying to get away from in health care
both in medical education and in public
policy um I'm going to share an
illustrative personal story because this
is a really important medical concept no
I'm not going to talk to you about myel
a lot to me 20 years I raced all over
the country and even all over the
world it was great I thought I would do
it forever then all of the sudden I was
training once and I felt my knee pop and
I knew I tore a cartilage
you know I knew what it was I knew what
it was and I went to see my friend who's
an orthopedic surgeon and he immediately
looked at me and said you need surgery
and I looked at him and I said you're
treating me as a knee not as a person
and I immediately thought of the
millions of different biological
psychological social functional issues
that played a role in me making a
complex medical decision I know I don't
look like a physical wreck but I also
have a herniated disc I also have carpal
tunn and both hands and both my knees
are bad and I've chosen to not have
surgery and I guarantee you most of the
people that I race with would have
chosen to have surgery and I bet a lot
of you out there would have chosen the
same what all these things have in
common with circumcision is that they
are all elective and they all require a
whole person patient centered analysis
different people make different choices
for those who choose surgery interesting
Medicaid covers all those elective
things
that is I already mentioned that all
right so circumcision has been around
for a long time um I did my research and
the first recorded on one I could come
up with was 4,000 years ago um since
that time frame there's been billions
billions of medic of circumcisions
performed on males and I tried to find
why there is no unifying reason why
every culture has a different reason but
in each of these cultures it's really
important to them
the magnitude of this suggests that we
as a people find Value in circumcision
for a variety of
reasons in the United States 70% of
males now are circumcised their
satisfaction rate is
90% contrast that with uncircumcised
males who only have a satisfaction rate
of 80% with their status and
interestingly one study found that 83%
of women prefer a male who's circumcised
says nothing about who's attached to the
genital but that's what they said one of
the things that we do know is that if
you're going to have this done the risk
benefit ratio favors doing this in the
newborn and there's clear evidence for
reductions in a variety of things that
the previous speaker already alluded to
complications happen but they're rare
and the severe complications we were
told about are extremely rare the other
is I'm sorry the minute the baby leaves
the newborn Nursery that may explain
that when Florida enacted a similar ban
they actually found that their Medicaid
C cost Rose they did not go down they
went up and the reason why is because
when you do it later it's dramatically
more
expensive one other thing that I found
that was interesting because some people
brought the cost issue into this is that
um anybody want to guess what the
reimbursement to uh an OB or whomever to
do a Medicaid circumcision this state is
it's $50 it's actually a little less
than $50 which is not enough to cover
cost and it is most definitely not
enough to cover opportunity cost meaning
the time that they could spend doing
something else with that said the I
interviewed a couple OB practices they
all said the same thing they said we do
it because it's patient choice and we
feel obligated to respect the wishes of
our
patient concluding circumcision for
complicated reasons remains an important
part of the American healthc care
Paradigm until there's a major paradigm
shift third party payment payers such as
Medicaid should respect the
recommendations the American The Academy
of family physicians and cover this
procedure and I would recommend at this
time until that day happens that we
you representative Burch has recognized
Speaker okay so let's talk about
Medicaid this is a bill designed to
remove circumcision from Medicaid
coverage in New
Hampshire circumcision like many
procedures covered by Medicaid is
considered by the medical profession as
beneficial as recommended but not
mandatory the professional groups that
deal with procedures like
circumcision uh are the American Academy
of Pediatrics not surprising and the
American College of Obstetricians and
gynecologists both have issued a policy
statement that states that for newborn
male circumcision the health
benefits outweigh any risks and such
benefits include prevention of
UTI penile cancer and transmission of
some sexually transmitted infections
such as HPV and
HIV if you want to reduce HPV a very
serious disease in our society today
that affects women and
men support
circumcision complications unlike what
we may have heard earlier complications
are infrequent according to the medical
profession usually quite minor and
serious complications are very
rare in addition to concluding that
newborn male circumcision is a medically
beneficial
procedure the medical Prof profession
also says and this is part of what
bothies say that third-party payments
are War
warranted that means
Medicaid so
question does or should Medicaid cover
beneficial recommended but non-mandatory
procedures actually it's a significant
part of what Medicaid does now we all
know that Medicaid is State administered
and varies from state to state so let's
talk about what New Hampshire covers
that that are beneficial but not
mandatory like
circumcision Dental
Care Vision
Care Chiropractic Ser
Services hearing
aids Physical
Therapy Petry
Services mental health
counseling smoking secession
programs weight l L programs and
bariatric surgery I could go on to more
so all of these are in the same
category as
circumcision this bill separates out
from all of those kind of
programs only one program
circumcision so enough of the medical
stuff it's a recommended procedure it's
a benefit IAL procedure there's no
bill let's also talk about the results
if this bill
passes we know the circumcisions are
performed across the entire spectrum of
males in New
Hampshire but it's clearly associated
with Jewish and Muslim
practice I am not arguing and I'll say
it again I am not arguing the difference
should be paid by the state to the
religious or cultural practices of any
religion or any group I am not arguing
that however I am saying that the
passage of this bill that sets
circumcision
apart from all the other beneficial but
not mandatory
procedures does send a
message it hangs a sign that says Jews
and Muslims are not quite as welcome in
New
Hampshire as others many will not see
that
sign but you can be sure that Muslims
and Jews
will the Democratic
chair in chesher county is a
Muslim we don't usually talk about bills
we do some administrative talk and he
does his work I do mine on this bill he
reached out to me probably the first
bill in five years and asked me to do
what could be done to have it
defeated we don't need to pass this bill
it's a minuscule program the
reimbursement as we heard is about $50
per
claim we should not pass this bill what
we need to do is treat our neighbors as
we would wish to be they to treat us and
you representative sod's recognized to
report thank you Mr Speaker I'm G to be
brief because I know this is a broad and
extensive topic but I'm going to clear
up some myths right here right
now
oh I want to clear up some myths right
here right now of what circumcision is
and is not circumcision is when 40 to
50% of orogy
tissue also known as the foreskin is cut
off a baby boy's
penis this is medically not necessary it
cures exactly
nothing this ayous tissue was put there
for a reason it is there to protect the
head of the penis and it is there to
enhance sexual pleasure
I and 80% of the male population on the
planet who are unaltered and intact can
attest to
this some of the
myths also are that Christianity is
adopted circumcision but it has not it
is a Jewish religious ceremony it is
part of the
Covenant M will suspend for minute there
should be one person speaking and he's
at the well continue yeah
it is part of the Jewish Covenant
Abraham was supposed to
sacrifice his
son but in the last
minute God said no instead we'll
sacrifice some sexual pleasure to bring
him closer to God by
cutting the
penis Christianity never or rather
Muslims also have this as part of their
tradition but they do not uh their time
intervals vary when they do it
Christians do not St Paul made it very
clear in the first century that
circumcision would not be part of
Christianity probably a great marketing
move because I don't think come to Jesus
cut a piece of your penis off would have
been a big
seller the next myth is that oh it's a
good old American tradition it is not
the men pictured on the wall behind me
circumcised because because the house
will be in order
it yes we do and that's not at the
current Speaker I'm just I'm the whole
thing continue please and let whole
just circumcision didn't become a thing
in the US until the late
1800s and didn't and it peaked in 1970
and it's been on the decline ever since
it was in the late 1800s when the
medicine was more snake oil than
science circumcision was promoted as a
Wonder cure for everything and we're
still wondering what it's curing because
debunked it was the it was during this
time that it was promoted by puritanical
prudish quacks who saw sex as the root
of all evil circumcision was meant to be
painful
and it is and it was meant to diminish
sexual pleasure by cutting off
aerogenous tissue they also had some
versions for women which included some
sort of acids as well but luckily for
women that never caught
on which brings us to this bill and
where I would ask the house today why we
the state are paying to diminish sexual
pleasure of poor
people I'll finish there I will answer
skin does the member yield for a
question
absolutely oh dear lord representative
wheeler you may
inquire you know there's a lot of times
in this body where I feel like I'm in
high school but none more than when the
entire body laughs laughs laughs at
every time the word penis is mentioned
but that's okay thank you representative
for taking my question I was just
looking into history I love history very
you know I like to be uh as well
informed as I can on these issues and I
found a doctor from San Diego who was
cited in many medical journals including
Boston's and Maryland's and others his
name is Peter ramundo and would you
believe representative that in his
medical journal written in 1894 that was
used for quite a long time he cited
circumcision and its benefits one of
them being from our observations and
experiences in such case we feel fully
warranted in suggesting the wholesale
circumcision of the Negro waste so as an
efficient remedy in preventing the
predisposition to discriminate
raping they want wanted to use
circumcision as a way to circumcise the
entire negro race to prevent them from
raping white women would you believe
that that was the justification used for
circumcision yes I would he was one of
the quacks that was promoting
circumcision back in the late
journal there were more than that to
representative gringer has requested a
roll call as that sufficiently seconded
no more questions more question it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
C the questions on the majority
committee report about to pass on House
Bill
94 representative Burch is recognized
if I
know that according to the American
Academy of Pediatrics and the American
College of Obstetricians and
gynecologists that circumcision is
beneficial surgery and that its health
benefits outweigh its risks in that it
helps prevent
UTI penile cancer and transmission of
sexually transmitted infections such as
HPV
and
HIV and the complications are infrequent
generally very
minor and if I know that Medicaid in New
Hampshire and elsewhere every day pays
for many beneficial but not mandatory
procedures and that the payment for
Medicaid from Medicaid for circumcision
is approximately
$50 and if I know that the medical
profession supports third-party payments
for circumcision because of its medical
benefits and finally if I believe that
the passage of this bill will make Jews
and Muslims feel less welcome in the
granted state would I press the red
button to vote against the OTP so that
another motion can be made thank you Mr
thank you Mr
Speaker representative McFarland's
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that we
rightly condemn female genital
mutilation as abhorent yet some of my
honorable colleagues would force
taxpayers to fund genital cutting when
it happens to
boys and if I know that this bill does
not ban circum ision but simply says
that the government should keep its
hands off where they don't
belong and if I
know that routine circumcision has no
medical
justification and that countries which
don't routinely circumcise have lower
rates of these
infrequent as the member from West
Millan puts it infections and
complications than we do
and if I know that we Americans can and
should make female orgasms greater
again and finally Mr Speaker if I know
that taxation is theft then would I now
vote to cut unnecessary spending in the
button the house will be in
order cooperate I'm standing between you
comfortable the question is on the
majority committee report about about to
pass on House Bill 94 and this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor press the
green button oppose press the red voting
[Music]
present
have all members present had an
opportunity to
vote the house will attend to the state
of the vote
184 in the
affirmative the house will be in
order 184 in the affirmative 183 in the
negative the committee reports adopted
and it's refer to finance and referred
to the committee on finance so you get
the house will be in recess for lunch
until
1:15
e
and order the chair recognizes the clerk
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I have a
a note from from the chair of the house
finance committee who is waving pursuant
to house rule 47f the referral of House
Bill 771 and House Bill 94 to the
for what reason does a member rise thank
you Mr Speaker to make a
motion sorry what a motion yeah State
your motion I move that the the debate
on House Bill 94 be added to the
permanent
journal the member moves that the house
that the debate on House Bill 94 be
entered in the permanent journal without
ordered the majority of the committee on
Health Human Services and elderly
Affairs to which was referred House Bill
223 an act relative to licensing
requirements for Health Care Facilities
that operate within 15 miles of a
critical access hospital having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill ought
you pass representative Yuri paulaz off
for the majority of the committee the
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
TR Tes for the minority of the committee
representative Tes is recognized to
report thank you Mr
Speaker New Hampshire is a rural State
and our critical access hospitals ensure
the health and well-being of the state's
Rural and medically underserved areas
providing access to Essential Health
Care Services such as Emergency Services
outpatient and inpatient care and care
coordination services to the state's
most rural residents who otherwise would
not have access to care it is in all our
interest to protect the financial
viability and survival of our 13
critical access hospitals which
represents half of our state's 26
hospitals this bill will undermine that
social contract removing an existing
stop Gap measure that currently assures
that proposed new healthc care
facilities will not have a detrimental
impact on the viability of our critical
access
hospitals
currently already any person or entity
can propose to establish a new Health
Care Facility within 15 miles of a
critical access Hospital the proposed
new healthcare facility can include an
ambulatory Surgical Center emergency
medical Care Center birthing center drop
in or walk-in Center dialysis center
special health care service or a
hospital the current well-functioning
process came out of a bipartisan study
committee and became law in 2020 and
simply provides a chance for a proper
review of the impact of the proposed
Healthcare
facility the current process
appropriately recognizes the fragility
of our critical access hospitals and
safeguards their importance in the
communities where they provide vital
care and
services the proposed bill would remove
the 15 Mile limit for almost all types
of healthc care facilities and allow
unchecked development of new healthc
care businesses that will likely
cherry-pick the more profitable patients
that are needed as part of the critical
access hospitals payer mix
this will directly undermine the
hospitals fiscal sustainability and put
more people in rural areas of New
Hampshire at risk of losing their
current access to the vital services
offered by these hospitals essential
services such as maternity and Emergency
Services we already have Healthcare
deserts let's not risk adding to those
significant and detrimental impacts by
facilitating the demise of our critical
access
hospitals for this reason I strongly
OTP representative McLean's recognized
report thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker HB 223 is a bill that
attempts to begin the process of opening
up the HealthCare Marketplace in the
rural areas of the state to new
approaches and providers to try to
counter the ongoing trend of declining
access in those communities all around
us we can see ongoing evidence that
services in the rural areas of this
state are going away without being
backfilled some quick examples in
October 2020 both Franklin hospital and
Lakes Region Hospital filed for chapter
11 bankruptcy and had to be zorbed in
conquered Hospital in order to survive
in 2023 frisbee Memorial hospital closed
its labor and delivery services and that
was the 11th Maternity Ward closure in
New Hampshire in the past 20 years in
2024 exitor Hospital proposed cuts to
neurology Pediatric Dental Advanced life
support Podiatry and Immunology and they
were only suspended because the Attorney
General got involved and on top of all
this New Hampshire as a whole has not
added a new hospital in 40 years years
in spite of the fact that over
450,000 new residents have come into the
state over that period of time part of
the problem is that we have fallen back
into a position where we are now relying
on the state's critical access hospitals
as the almost exclusive provider of
non-primary Health Care in the rural
areas of this state and that would be
fine except that these hospitals are at
a Breaking Point and the current law
throws up heavy barriers to exploring
any
alternatives one of the barriers that
this bill seeks to tear down is the 15m
radial exclusion Zone around critical
access hospitals the bill gets rid of it
right now no healthc care facility can
get approval to build a facility in an
exclusion Zone without first getting the
approval of the impacted critical access
hospital but as you can imagine that
approval is hard to get as hospitals are
very eager to maintain their exclusivity
in any given area former HHS
commissioner Nick veas who supports this
bill and came in to testify on its
behalf he testified in committee that
when he was on the old certificate of
need board he would watch Hospital
presidents come in and flat out lie in
order to protect their Turf so you might
say a 15mi radius is no big deal right
just built outside it right but the
problem is when you overlay all the
exclusion zones on on a map the only
area outside of the those zones is in
the extreme Southeastern portion of the
state that's why you can have a
convenient MD in Manchester or Salem but
not in the state's rural areas HB 223
solves the problem by eliminating the
exclusion zones so that other facilities
might explore Alternatives that might
collectively build towards a sustainable
model and you know we just heard some
say that if this bill pass it's going to
wipe out critical access hospitals but
the reality is that the rural areas of
the state just don't have the population
to make a widespread business model
business case for widespread clinical
expansion the real threat to our
critical access hospitals is time the
existing model is not sustainable and if
we do nothing rural access will be wiped
out by nothing more than the passage of
time
Mr Speaker it's better to take a small
risk now than a huge risk in the midst
of a full-on crisis in the future this
bill does make one exception to the
repeal of the exclusion zones so while
the repeal allows for ambulatory
surgical centers dialysis centers
birthing centers and others to be exempt
from the exclusion Zone Provisions it
maintains the prohibition on building
another hospital in the critical access
exclusion Zone and the reason that it
does that is the bill took great care to
preserve the critical the federal
critical access status of our critical
access hospitals so that even with this
bill they can maintain their favorable
Medicare reimbursement rates so I think
this bill is a reasonable compromise and
I hope you will support it thank you Mr
Speaker
division a division vote has been
requested this will be a division vote
members take your seats who requested a
King representative King request a roll
call is ask sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded members take your
the questions on the majority committee
report about to pass on house Buu 23
representative Weber is recognized for a
parliamentary
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that our
critical access hospitals are just that
critical and if I know that siphoning
off Revenue that is critical to the
survival of critical access hospitals is
not going to help them
survive would I now press the red button
to vote against ought to pass so another
motion can be made thank
you members are reminded if you shut
your voting station off turn it back on
if you're here representative McDonald
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill will confront
the decline in medical access and the
High Cost of Medical Care in New
Hampshire and Mr Speaker if I know this
will be achieved through the exempting
of ambulatory surgical centers Emergency
Medical Care Centers birthing centers
walk-in Care Centers dialysis centers
and special health care services from
the critical access Hospital
exclusionary Zone
restrictions then Mr Speaker if I know
these things would I then press the
green button and support off to pass
thank you the questions on the majority
committee report of about pass an S Bill
223 and this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor press the green button
oppose press the red voting stations are
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 213 and the affirmative 158 and the
the majority of the committee on Health
Human Services and elderly Affairs to
which was referred House Bill 524 FN an
act repealing the New Hampshire vaccine
Association having considered the same
report the same with the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass
representative Lisa merer for the
majority of the committee the minority
of the committee have been considered
the same and being unable to agree with
the majority Report with the following
resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to to legislate
representative Jessica lanin for the
minority of the committee for what
rise I'd like to make a motion Mr
Speaker State your
motion Mr Speaker I would like to make a
motion to lay House Bill 524 FN on the
table and I request a division read she
wants what she wants a
divisions okay so you're just asking for
a division vote
okay all right the motion is to lay
House Bill 524 on the table
representative Granger requests a roll
call is that sufficiently
seconded it is this will be a roll call
clear the motion is to lay House Bill
524 on the table representative Weber is
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that the New Hampshire vaccine
Association is a very popular program
that reduces costs by
30% increases efficiency and increases
access for those who want vaccines
without coercing anybody else to have
them and if I know that it is therefore
a very parent friendly bill because
program because it allows parents to
choose exactly what kind of treatments
they want for their
children would I now vote to table this
bill so we can go on to a more
productive
debate representative kofos recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that taxpayers deserve
answers as to why the New Hampshire
vaccine Association has repeatedly
refused to reimburse the state for the
nearly $1 million annual cost of our
vaccine
program and if I know that the false
claims again about this
bill that this bill would negatively
impact New Hampshire families deserve a
response on this house floor so that we
can decide this bill on its
merits and finally Mr Speaker if I know
that the New Hampshire vaccine
Association suffers from a disturbing
lack of transparency and accountability
and that tabling this bill would obscure
the issue even further by preventing
debate would I then press the red button
to defeat this motion so that we can
continue with the floor debate thank you
Mr
Speaker questions whether to lay House
Bill 524 on the table and this is roll
call vote if you're in favor press the
green button opposed press the red
[Music]
represent
dry have all members present at an
opportunity to vote the house attend to
the state of the
vote 175 in the affirmative 198 and the
fails back to the main motion of uh to
pass representative lontan is recognized
report thank you Mr
Speaker I Rise Against the UT to pass
motion on HB 524
which would repeal the New Hampshire
vaccine
Association the association is a
nonprofit organization established
decades ago to save money and ensure
every child has access to
vaccines it is a great example of a
public and private partnership that
works well it combines money from 90
commercial insurers with Federal
vaccines for children funds to
seamlessly purchase and distribute
vaccines across the state to more than
200 Pediatric and
family practices it is not a tax as some
has suggested it is more like a
voluntary Buying Club that reduces the
cost of vaccines for Everyone by
30% it decreases overhead for private
practices so they don't have to
carefully maintain their own inventory
vories nor directly Bill insurers for
every
shot it ensures that every child who
enters the doctor's office or clinic can
get the recommended vaccines at no
cost there is no evidence that there is
any fraud at the New Hampshire vaccine
Association not a single insurer nor
medical
provider spoke in favor of its repeal
and in fact they staunchly defended the
New Hampshire vaccine
Association DHHS opposes this bill it
does not cost the state
anything in fact if it's repealed it
will cost the state money because DHHS
will then have to maintain an inventory
of vaccines to maintain in case of an
outbreak the system works and does not
need fixing
so what is the point of this
bill dissolving the New Hampshire
vaccine Association will result in fewer
children being vaccinated in the Granite
State this will result in outbreaks of
preventable diseases as we have seen
happening in the US where vaccination
rates have
declined vaccines have saved more lives
than any other medical intervention in
history if you don't believe that I have
one word for you
polio do you think polio is not a
problem anymore there have been recent
cases of paralytic po polio in
unvaccinated
communities this is a tragedy I know
something about
personally my husband's father
contracted polio in the
1955 epidemic in
Massachusetts he was a healthy
34-year-old World War II vet who came
home from work on a Friday afternoon
feeling like he had the flu and he never
walked
again he had one of the worst cases of
the most severe form of polio to
survive the cruel irony is that all four
of his children including my husband
were vaccinated the year before but they
hadn't rolled out the so vaccine for
adults yet the children were fine but
Bruce do did survive while many died
and he lived another 21 years paralyzed
from the neck down most of the time in
an iron lung because dis the disease
destroyed his voluntary nervous system
and he could not breathe without it
without him an iron lung and I knew him
as a child as our families were close
and I still remember overcoming my fear
as a little girl of The Man in the
machine with just his head sticking out
despite his paralysis he played a
powerful role as a father in a member of
his community and his family was
grateful that he
survived still my husband might have
been happier to have a more normal
childhood where he could hike with his
father in the whites and play ball and
not be changing his bed
pan let us not go backward with the
progress we've made in
vaccines and please vote no on to
pass representative kofos recognized to
speak in support of the committee
report thank you Mr
Speaker let me say first and
foremost this bill has nothing to do
whatsoever with the merits of vaccines
or the lack thereof it's not about more
vaccines or fewer
vaccines in fact the NIH did a study and
found that compulsory bulk purchase
programs for vac vacines do not impact
vaccination
rates so the New Hampshire vaccine
Association is probably something that
most of you don't know a lot about I
didn't know a lot about it until I
started to research this bill and the
more I learned the more questions I
had this is a nonprofit organization
created by the legislature in 2002 under
RSA
126q but the New Hampshire vaccine
Association is is not like any other
nonprofit
organization for one thing it has the
power to Levy
assessments I would call those taxes
because they are compulsory payments
levied against the insurance
carriers they are not optional they are
not
voluntary in fact the statute contains
Provisions saying
that the state can revoke licenses of
insurance
carriers that fail to make payment they
can also
uh Levy fines and penalties for late
voluntary secondly I find it very
interesting that the New Hampshire
vaccine Association member director
members
directors um employees and agents are
shielded from all liability they are
immune from liability under the statute
the New Hampshire vaccine Association
asserts that because it is a separate
nonprofit organization it is not subject
to our right to know law
91a and they have Obed to even such
simple measures as posting their Zoom
meetings their monthly meetings online
they said it would be burdensome to do
so so Zoom has a feature that you can
live turn on very easily live stream to
YouTube and it's posted and um
maintained online so I think the
assertion that
hyperbole so what we see is uh is an
organization created under estate law
that is unlike any other nonprofit that
I'm aware of and that suffers from a
disturbing lack of transparency and
accountability so what does the vaccine
Association do well every year they work
with the Department of Health and Human
Services to estimate the number of doses
of vaccines that are going to be
required for insured children in the
state
they collect money or assessments from
the insurance carriers and they uh they
provide that those funds for bulk
purchase of
vaccines now this only covers insured
children so insured children are covered
for vaccines under the Affordable Care
Act insurance carriers are required to
pay 100% of those costs there's no
co-pay so if this bill doesn't
pass families get those those vaccines
without any kind of co-payment if this
does pass families get those vaccines
without any kind of
co-payment let's talk about uninsured
children this doesn't affect them
vaccines for uninsured children and
Medicaid are purchased through the or or
acquired through a federally funded
children so ostensibly the program by by
assessing money from from the insurance
carriers um in in engaging in this bulk
purchase of vaccines ostensibly it's
saving
money but does it really and at what
cost the Bill's opponents have cited
cost of $200 to $400 per dose depending
on the vaccine that is an an MSRP it's a
little bit like the MSRP you see um on
car ads nobody actually pays
it but by by negotiating a 30% discount
on that presumably they're passing that
on to the insurance
carriers it's interesting however that
not a single insurance carrier showed up
at the at the bill hearing to testify
against this bill only six states have
compulsory vaccine bulk bulk vaccine
purchase programs like New Hampshire's
most of them date back uh many many
years and Most states have rejected such
programs as being too costly and
so although I am yet to be convinced it
is possible that insurance carriers are
saving a bit of
money if that is the case then they are
doing that at a cost to New Hampshire
taxpayers every year the Department of
Health and Human Services incurs
costs of close to a million dollars for
running the vaccine program for fisal
year
61 every year they submit a request to
the New Hampshire vaccine Association to
pay 60% of that cost because 60% of the
vaccines purchased
are covered under the New Hampshire
vaccine Association
program the vaccine Association in 2018
issued a letter stating that they had no
intention of ever paying this they don't
believe that the statute authorizes it
so they're not covering it that leaves
as I said before those who argue that
this affects vaccination rates in any
way
um are are wrong the NIH studied
compulsory uh programs like this and
said that they were quote ineffective in
increasing vaccination rates and
recommended that quote policy makers
seeking to increase vaccination rates
would do well to consider other policies
such as addressing provider practice
hesitancy so finally I'd like to Circle
back to to the the false claims that
this bill would negatively impact
families there was a a an editorial that
appeared recently in one of our
newspapers in New Hampshire stating that
the uh vaccine Association quote removes
access and financial barriers for
parents who want their child to be
immunized that is not the
case they don't pay anything for the
vaccine when they go to the doctor today
and if this bill is passed passed and
becomes law they won't pay anything for
it tomorrow or a year from now or 5
now the claim that any child would have
any less vaccine coverage is patently
false House Bill 524 would not only
reduce any new Co would not result in
any new cost for families it would
simply eliminate a a bureaucracy that
serves no legitimate purpose and that
suffers from a disturbing lack of
transparency and accountability
Mr Speaker I urge my colleagues to
support this
bill so that we can get uh transparency
and accountability for New Hampshire
taxpayers and get government out of this
business thank you Mr Speaker
call Representative Granger requests a
roll call is that sufficiently
seconded oh sure everybody wants it this
will be a roll call vote members take
your
questions on the majority committee
report of ought to pass on House Bill
520 four representative lon's recognized
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I knew that there was no
credible evidence of any kind of fraud
presented about the VA I mean the
vaccination
Association and if I
knew that not a single insurance company
came to support this bill
and that many medical providers came to
oppose the bill if I knew the public had
overwhelming support
or spoke overwhelmingly against this
bill and if I know that dissolving the
vaccine Association will make it harder
for children to be vaccinated in the
state and if I know that this will will
result in lower vaccination rates and
potentially
outbreaks would I press the red button
so that a better motion may be brought
forward representative McDonald's
inquir thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that while well intentioned
the New Hampshire vaccine Association is
not a costeffective program and it would
be more efficient for vaccine providers
to purchase and control their own
vaccine inventories to meet the needs of
the patients they
serve and Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill will not increase the costs of
parents through deductibles or co-pays
because Federal Law requires that all
vaccines for children be provided at no
cost to the parent Mr Speaker if I know
these things would I then press the
green button and vote ought to
pass the questions on the majority
committee report about to pass an House
Bill 524 this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor press the green button
oppos press the red voting stations are
[Music]
represent
Tesa represent Doug
have all members present had an
opportunity to
vote the house will attend to the state
of the
vote 189 in the affirmative 181 and the
adopted that's going to
means House Bill 524 is referred to the
for what reason does the member rise
move that the debate on HB 524 be placed
in the permanent Journal please without
order the majority of the committee on
Health Human Services and elderly
Affairs to which is referred our bill
634 an act relative to the New Hampshire
Council on autism spectrum disorders
having considered the same report the
same with the following Amendment and
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass with Amendment representative
Jim kofalt for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass representative Lucy Weber
for the minority of the committee the
amendment is
03448 prined in house record 14 on page
representative Stringham is recognized
amendment thank you Mr Speaker I Rise to
speak against uh this amendment this
amendment would
repeal the New Hampshire Council on
autism spectrum
disorders uh the this Council operates
at no cost to the taxpayers and its
members accumulate information
about autism spectrum disorders uh and
provide educational resources and advice
to those affected by
autism House Bill 634 as written is a
bipartisan housekeeping bill that was
written to reinvigorate this Council it
was brought to this legislature by those
who have recently taken over the
committee and tried to reinvigorate it
now that the impacts of Co have been and
settled
down it does a few simple things it more
tightly defines the purposes of the
commission that makes it more realistic
for a commission run by volunteers with
no cost to
achieve it allows remote participation
for those with disability to participate
in the commission it expands the
membership by two members and it Alters
the nominating process for members to to
avoid vacancies for example right now
there are seven openings on the council
and five are nominated by the governor
the council has met several times in the
past year but with so many openings they
did not achieve a
quorum one thing the council did do was
come to us the legislature and ask us to
make some changes to their Charters and
rules so that they could be effective
for those with autism spectrum disorders
the amendment that we're talking about
is predicated on the assumption that the
work of this committee could be
performed by the development service
quality Council but many people with
autism spectrum disorder do not meet the
legal definition of disability so those
people would not be represented at all
uh in that committee the energetic and
experienced people who are
reinvigorating this Council feel there's
an unmet need with that can only be done
by this
Council so with the housekeeping changes
and the highquality individuals who are
now in place supporting those with
autism spectrum disorders the better
solution for us is to vote read on the
amendment so that this original
bipartisan bill can be
passed and so I would ask uh for you to
vote r on the amendment and Mr Speaker I
ask for a division vote thank
you representative Drews recognized to
amendment thank you Mr Speaker the case
for this bill as amended is simple the
council has not met since 2019 and has
not submitted a annual report since
2017 there have been many opportunities
to revive the council but it has not
happened we learned from constituents
that this coun 's mission is largely
duplicative of the work already being
done by the New Hampshire developmental
Services quality Council thus I have
urge you I urge you to vote for the
amendment and repeal this defunct
Council thank
you a division vote has been requested
this will be a division vote members
the questions on the adoption of
amendment 0344 H this is a division vote
representative Weber is recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that the council as
reconstituted would provide a much
needed specialty lens for those people
with autism spectrum disorder and if I
know that those people will not be
adequately represented on the
developmental Services quality Council
because many of them do not meet the
definition of disabled would I now press
red to defeat the amendment so we could
pass the original
Bill representative McDonald's
thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that the
repeal of this body makes sense because
as was pointed out it has not meant
since 2019 and it has not issued an
annual report since
2017 and Mr Speaker if I know that the
mission of the New Hampshire Council on
autism spectrum disorders is already
being performed by the New Hampshire
developmental Services quality Council
and Mr Speaker if I know that numerous
parents of autistic children
contacted me and other members of the
health human services and elderly
Affairs committee and urged the repeal
of this body Mr Speaker if I know these
things would I then press the green
button and vote ought to
pass the questions on the adoption of
amendment 0344 H this is a division vote
if you're in favor press the green
button oppose press the red voting
[Music]
have all members present and an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 2011 on the affirmative 171 in
negative the Amendments
adopted now onto the main motion of a to
pass as amended are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I all
those oppose
nay the eyes have it and the committee
just so everybody knows I just finished
reading through every single blurb for
next week so we'll have our full
calendar for next week
too committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs to which
was referred Health Bill 704 FN a an act
relative to caregiver respite and Senior
volunteer programs making an
appropriation therefore having consider
the same report the same with the
recommendation the bill ought to pass
sen Susan Dumis for the committee are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say I I I suppose nay the eyes
have it and the committee report is
majority of the committee on Health and
Human Services and eldy Affairs to which
was referred House Bill 724 FN now
relative to lead paint poisoning
prevention and Remediation considered
the same report the same with a
following resolution resolved that as
inexpedient to legislate of Matt Drew
for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with a
recommendation the bill ought to pass
representative Jessica lontine from the
minority of the committee for what
reason does the member
rise Mr Speaker is a motion to divide
yes
yes so Mr Speaker I would move to divide
out section two from the rest of the
bill
two oh okay sorry I'm told I need to ask
you first first if that section is
divisible is section two divisible yes
it is thank you and now that we know
that section two is divisible may we
vote on section two
first and then vote on the other three
sections
together oh and can we ensure that the
effective date is effective for both
parts
all right the motion before the house is
the question on whether we divide
section two out of the
bill it is divisible does everybody
question okay the question is on the
division of section two out of House
Bill
724 and this is a division vote so
repres
all right the the motion before us is to
on the on the motion to divide the
question the chair recognizes
representative Harkin Phillips for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
[Music]
Speaker if I know that the original
intent of the bill was to provide four
no cost solutions to prevent lead
poisoning in our children and if I also
know that during the drafting process
the second section
related to lowering the blood lead level
threshold
reductions uh I'm sorry thresholds from
5 micrograms to the 3.5 micrograms in
fact carried a very Hefty burden during
a difficult budget
cycle and if I would prefer to have u a
vote on the merits of the remaining
three sections at no cost to our state
then would I now press the green button
to divide the question for section two
Speaker chair recognize representative
Wayne McDonald for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
whether you support this bill or not
it's an important issue this bill
deserves to be considered in its its
entire as written and I would urge you
to vote down the motion to divide press
the red
button okay the motion before us is
whether we are going to divide the
question this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
repr
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
vote 163 voting a 23 voting a the motion
fails we're back to the original motion
of inexpedient to
legislate on uh House Bill 724 for what
reason does a member rise thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker I move to inde Ely
724 okay the motion before us is
definitely postpone House Bill 724 that
is a proper motion a roll call has been
called that is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
yes all right the the motion before us
is indefinitely postponed on House Bill
vote chair recognize representative hkin
thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that New Hampshire has
a lead poisoning problem for our
children and despite good faith efforts
to improve the law in 2018 New Hampshire
is experiencing an uptick in the amount
of children who are being lead poisoned
a
year if I also know that the underlying
Bill presents four C cost saving
measures to the state which have no
fiscal impact to prevent lead poisoning
in our children before it
happens and if I also
know that the heart of the issue Mr
Speaker is between who will bear the
burden of resolving lead poisoning in
New Hampshire's children between the
property owners or tax paays and finally
Mr Speaker if I
know that this ch Amber was sent um by
our electorate to govern to solve
problems and New Hampshire's problem of
lead poisoning is on a runaway course
then would I now press the red button to
indefinitely postpone HB 72 so that we
can have an underlying a debate on the
underlying issue thank you Mr
Speaker chair recognize representative
Wayne McDonald for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill creates a significant expense for
landlords without resolving the issue of
lead paint poisoning and
Remediation and Mr Speaker if I know
this because lead paint abatement is not
only expensive but does not fully remove
the hazard and the hazard can be
repeatedly
reexposed Mr Speaker if I know these
things would I then press the green
button and vote to indefinitely postpone
this legislation thank you the motion be
for us is indefinitely postponed on
House Bill 724 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
represent
jurus all memb present had an
opportunity to vote how attend to stay
202 voting aay 167 voting nay House Bill
724 is inde definitely
cpon
representative Jim
M representative Jim McCay declared a
conflict and recuse himself from the
vote
majority of the committee on Health and
Human Services and elderly Affairs to
which was referred House Bill 751 FN act
relative to certification of alcohol and
other substance misuse treatment
facilities consider the same report the
same with the following Amendment the
recommendation the bill ought to pass
with Amendment Senor Mark mlan for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the following resolution resolved
that as inexpedient to late pres of Jim
kofalt for the minority of the
committee the amendment is
0220 printed in house record 14 page 58
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I iose
nay the eyes have it the amendment is
adopted the motion before us now is
ought to pass with Amendment the chair
thank you Mr
Speaker Mr
Speaker in the world of substance abuse
recovery everybody has heard of 12-step
programs the most famous being
alcoholics or Narcotics Anonymous
however one step that everybody
navigating the road to recovery needs to
be aware of is the 13th Step In This
step the person who is new to the
recovery program is targeted for a
sexual relationship by a counselor or a
person further along in their recovery
journey I can think a few things as file
as praying on people in the very
vulnerable state of overcoming addiction
sadly in New Hampshire The 13th Step is
incredibly widespread and it's very hard
to get a handle on because the substance
abuse treatment landscape in New
Hampshire is almost completely
unregulated HB 751 addresses this issue
by establishing a license program for
out patient substance abuse treatment
facilities and creating an utman
position to investigate and resolve
complaints the bill originally came to
us last year and it was full of holes
there was no way the committee could
have passed it but the amendment we just
passed really tightened up the bill it
took out residential
facilities explicitly Exempted
non-clinical programs like AA and
streamline the process by Rolling the
certification into the existing
Healthcare care facili licensing statute
instead of creating a separate licensing
infrastructure so this is a very clean
bill we heard testimony in committee
from a woman whose son went to treatment
for alcoholism six times before he died
after his death they came to learn that
everything he was told to do well in
treatment was wrong and completely
non-evidence-based he didn't need to die
we heard testimony from a woman working
in Corrections Who mandated other women
into substance abuse treatment when the
woman she sent into treatment came back
and told her that she'd been sexually
abused she investigated and discovered
that five other women that she had sent
to the same facility had met a similar
fate the realization that she had forced
these women into the hands of their
abusers horrified her and she has worked
ever since to put guard rails and
protections around treatment the final
words she said to the committee were
these I've worked 11 years to create
some kind of protection for those going
through substance abuse treatment and
this bill is the closest we have ever
come Mr Speaker we owe it to her and all
those navigating the very difficult
journey to recovery to finally get this
done there are those who oppose the bill
as potentially creating unnecessary
regulations but I just want to ensure
them that I am a huge limited government
guy huge but this is a clean bill and
limited government does not mean no
government without some rules in the
Playbook those walking no waya out of
addiction will continue to walk under
the tyranny of the Predator the abuser
and the Spectre of unnecessary relapse
for those that walk this hard path this
bill represents the release from tyranny
and the freedom to walk through their
recovery Journey without fear the mayor
of Manchester himself a recovered addict
talked to me about this bill he said you
know Mark when you release someone from
Valley Street jail and they are clean we
have a rare opportunity to keep them
that way and that opportunity is lost if
they're placed in the counseling with
someone who has not themselves completed
their own recovery Journey we need this
bill colleagues I ask you to support the
committee recommendation of octop passes
amended thank you Mr Speaker
representative grer has requested a roll
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
the motion before us is a to pass the
majority committee report of Auto passes
am on House Bill 751 this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you press the
green button if you oppose you press the
red button voting stations are open for
[Music]
represent
Burton thumbs up or down please sir
all members president had an opportunity
vote 26 voting aay 1502 voting nay the
finance committee on Health and Human
services and elderly Affairs to which
was referred House Bill 756 FN relative
establishing a blood level testing
requirement for children entering
daycare in public schools this comes
without
recommendation representative Wayne
McDonald moves inexpedient to legislate
toise thank you Mr Speaker
we all want to see all of New
Hampshire's children be healthy and
Thrive however childhood lead poisoning
is on the rise in New Hampshire with
nearly 5,000 New Hampshire children over
the past 5 years having experienced
elevated blood lead levels high enough
to impair their ability to think
concentrate and
learn lead is a naturally occurring
toxic metal and there is no known safe
blood level concentration
exposure to very high levels can
severely damage the brain and central
nervous system causing coma convulsions
and even death children who do
survive may be left with permanent
intellectual disability and behavioral
disorders resulting in long-term
significant costs for those individuals
as well as their families communities
and New Hampshire
taxpayers New Hampshire has aging
housing stock which puts our families at
risk of lead poisoning as lead dust too
tiny to see on hands toys or surfaces
can have serious and permanent effects
on a child's growth and development the
only way to detect blood poisoning is
through a simple blood test that is why
all New Hampshire children should be
tested at age 1 and again at age two
during their well child check medical
visits
regly currently significant numbers of
children are not tested at
all given the potentially devastating
impacts of lead on children's developing
brains and the very concerning low
numbers of one and two-year-old children
currently tested for blood lead levels
this bill provides an important stop Gap
opportunity for increasing the blood
testing of infants and
children there are already health record
records that have to be submitted when a
child goes to daycare or starts public
school this bill presents an important
opportunity to lower the number of
children who fall through the
Gap adding a simple checkbox to the
existing process provides one more
opportunity for children to be tested to
protect New Hampshire Children's Health
and
well-being for this reason I strongly
urge no on the motion of itl
kofalt thank you Mr Speaker uh this bill
adds a uh a step to the process of
enrolling a child in school or
daycare uh it doesn't actually add
additional lead testing requirements we
already require children to be tested at
age one and then again at age
two the reporting requirement really
needs to be administered by the school
or Child Care Agency so it is
essentially um putting the burdens of of
doing that on those organizations You
could argue that's not a huge burden but
there is also a notification requirement
so they then have to send out a
notification to parents um that this is
required uh if the if the parent has not
provided proof that the child has been
tested um and once they provide that
notification there doesn't appear to be
any further um enforcement mechanism so
um really we see this as as an
unnecessary and burdensome Bill uh we
already require lead testing and uh it
places unnecessary burdens on uh schools
and Child Care Centers so I urge my my
colleagues uh to uh to support the itl
motion roll call Mr Speaker Weber has
asked for roll call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficient seconded this
will be a roll call vote members take
the motion before us is any expedience
to legislate on House Bill 756 this is
the roll call vote chair recognizes
representative Weber for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I thought that not adding
another mandate might be a good
thing but if I know that blood level
lead levels are rising in our children
and testing is not keeping up and if I
know that this just offers another
opportunity to get people tested and
treated for a horrible disease if
necessary preventing further harm would
I now press red on the itl so another
motion can be
brought chair recognize representative
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that New
Hampshire already requires children to
be tested for LED at both ages one and
Age Two and Mr Speaker if I know that
this bill more than anything else simply
imposes additional administrative
burdens on Child Care Centers and
schools Mr Speaker if I know these
things would I then press the green
button and vote this bill inexpedient to
legislate thank you the motion before us
is in the majority uh inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 756 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the right button voting
[Music]
G all members president had an
opportunity to vote Al will attend to
aded representative Barry declared a
participate majority committee on
Judiciary to which was referred House
Bill 114 FN an act removing fees and
charges for governmental records under
the right to no law and reinstating
potential liability for disclosure of
information exempt from disclosure
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolve that is inexpedient to legislate
pres of Eric Tura for the majority of
the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the recommendation the bill ought to
pass representative Louise Andress from
the minority of the committee the
question is on the motion of inexpedient
to legislate on House Bill 114 RN are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say I I I oppos name
the eyes have it and the committee
adopted majority committee on labor
industrial and rehabilitative services
to which was referred House Bill 378 FN
act relative to employees unused earned
time having considered the same report
the same with the following resolution
resolve that is inexpedient to legislate
Mr Andre Pro for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following Amendment the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass with
Amendment representative Michael kahill
for the minority of the committee the
kahill thank you Mr
Speaker uh Mr Speaker this is not a new
issue to this
body uh I don't know if this is the
sixth or seventh I'm not sure if this is
the sixth or the seventh time that we've
talked about this issue but for the
benefit of the new members I'm going to
go through some of the stories why I
keep on bringing this
back uh one of them involved an assisted
living center in my town of New
Market which uh the uh owner of the
business sold the business right to
do the member has a right to be heard
and it's getting awful awful noisy in
here thank you Mr continue uh the owner
of this Assisted Living Center sold the
business and five or several of the
current employees transferred to the new
owner they knew the jobs well they knew
the patience and this was a good thing
for
both uh five of these people found that
uh when they got their next paycheck
from the new
employer the uh the acred vacation was
gone and there had been no payment from
the previous employer for said hours so
they filed the claim with the Department
of Labor the New Hampshire Department of
Labor and you and I might agree that
something was wrong there and that when
you do earn something your vacation time
you earn it it belongs to you and while
some companies may have a policy about
use it or lose it you have amount of
time with which you must use it and
after that you lose some it doesn't all
get carried over there's a lot of
variety in this but in general and I
don't know maybe you've experienced
yourself in your own life where if your
company changes hands it's required
there's an acquisition normally what
happens is you stay on everything's
grandfathered over you don't lose
anything that you once again you've
earned it in this case that's not what
happened and because they the employer's
policy was uh upon upon
termination uh vacation has not
p no this way that way no circumstances
just upon termination even though it was
the employer's decision to do it and I
have no quarrel with him selling the
business it's his right to do so I just
think he should have taken better care
of his employees in one way or the
other uh the other story I'm going to
tell you because they these of these
people there were five of them five
claims they lost you know $ four or $500
a piece and this is 2014 when that was
real money
um another story is someone I knew who
worked as a shipper for a computer
company sort of a salvage computer
company a lot of those popped up when
everybody was buying
computers and she was a shipper and she
would you know dutifully ship the
product and get it done and then the
policy in that and this she had two she
if you had vacation time and you wanted
to have a take the vacation you needed
to ask the manager two weeks ahead of
time which is reasonable to say because
you know they have to allow for the
business to move forward someone to take
over that job while you're away on
vacation so she had three weeks of
vacation H but when she went in that
when she went into work one day not
knowing that this was going to happen
she was laid off so because she was
unable to give two weeks uh request a
vacation two weeks in advance she lost
all that wage equivalent which is
$2,300 in change
now I think most of us could agree that
that was not right that you know she had
no control over the decision she had she
hadn't done anything wrong she I think
she worked there for seven years or so
and so why should she lose what she had
earned but that's what
happened
um I'm going to tell you another
story I'm not I'm I'm not going to go on
much longer with the stories but they're
all kind of
interesting um you know because when
nowadays we have so many people working
remotely maybe you know people that are
doing that and there's a woman who uh
had a
job uh she was working from home but
working for an employer and she was
there about three and a half
years and their policy had been up
until up until November of 23 the policy
had been when you leave you give notice
and you work your notice we will pay you
your your time that was the policy but
in November of 23 uh it changed to we
will pay you your time if the law if the
state in which you live requires us to
do it so there are people who will do
what they can and there's people who do
what they have to do so in this case uh
she filed the wage claim and because she
lived in New Hampshire which does not
have that protection I guess I'd call
this the New Hampshire disadvantage uh
she did not have that protection and she
lost some uh uh
$1,200 and that's in this year's
money
um so what this bill does what this bill
does is it
says um if you if you are laid off if
your company is sold or it goes out of
business you will get paid what you have
accured there's because because there's
a lot of variety in the way companies do
this some have the acral system which
was more common when I was working and
some to well it's all One bank it's all
PTO and this this seems to cause a
problem for some because I said um you
don't have to pay the sick time because
we don't want you to get sick but if you
do get sick we're going to pay you for
that day because we didn't want you to
come in and give it to everybody else we
hope you feel better but a vacation
you've earned it we expect you to take
the vacation we don't expect to to uh
keep that money under any circumstances
we expect you to be rested and take the
vacation so some people find that
because they say it's
PTO um all One bank if you said that in
the beginning that's you should leave it
that way you don't have to take it all
apart and try to reverse reverse the
problem it's it's not not complicated at
all whatever you said it was if it's all
One Bank you don't have to worry about
the V the sick days just pay them cuz
that's what you said you were going to
do but you should pay them if they if
they leave and it's beyond their control
it's because you had a lay off maybe
something's changed in the company you
you know you don't need that person
you're going to need a different person
you lay that person off and what's he
going to do he's going to go collect
unemployment and when he collects
unemployment they're going to say did
you get any severance pay you have any
vacation pay and if he does have
vacation pay that gets reduced so he's
not getting paid until he's used that
Severance or vacation pay we're
protecting the uh the trust fund so
there's a number of good reasons other
than the moral one that it's the right
thing to do and many of you if you have
been an employer I'm sure you would you
would take care of your people and not
just say well I'll just put this money
in my pocket
so um I want to draw your attention to
the committee report by my good friend
from
Hudson in which he says that it will
require employers to change what they're
doing and it really doesn't it just
says if you if you have PTO it's really
all just PTO it's under this this bill
is under very very limited narrow
circumstances not somebody who just
walks in and quits and leaves the
employer short like that this is really
a very narrow and uh practical Bill and
since we want to treat our employer
employees as well as we in treat
employers I urge you to defeat the
itl and uh give us another opportunity
to uh pass this bill uh I remind I'm
reminded that my good friend from Hudson
himself Works in a company Massachusetts
and has benefited from the law that they
have there and I wish he would extend
that benefit to the people of New
Hampshire thank you Mr
proud we'll find
out thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker this
bill would add several new requirements
onto businesses regarding employee
vacation time specifically written
policies with specific items and require
new internal processes that must meet
specific requirements it strictly
defines different types of time off
vacation versus sick time in ways that
do not necessarily comport with how
businesses operate today in short it
reduces the flexibility of employers to
manage the relationship with their
employees forcing this one Siz fits-all
model with non-compliance traps that
businesses get in trouble uh and will
add extra expenses and burdens to small
businesses the requirements of this bill
can mostly be avoided by a business
adopting an unfavorable vacation time
expiration policy that focuses on
protecting the business a recommendation
I'm sure many business owners will
receive I've experienced this personally
when I Massachusetts adopted similar
changes to their sick time laws my
employer drastically changed their
policies to comply and none of the
changes were better for the
employees additionally this bill applies
retroactively it would apply not just a
vacation time earned in the future but
also existing vacation time or earned
time already granted to existing
employees however that may have been
defined in the past businesses that
aren't paying careful attention to the
changes in the law may get caught
unaware and see significant new
liabilities suddenly show up on their
balance
sheet finally existing laws allow the
Department of Labor to investigate
claims that businesses have not not
follow their own vacation policies and
take enforcement actions in the majority
of cases this bill isn't needed thank
you Mr Speaker and I urge everyone to
press the green button on the itl motion
represent kill's request that a roll
call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
seats
C
the motion before us is the m majority
committee report of inex spe to
legislate and House Bill
378 this is a roll call vote chair
recognized representative Brian Sullivan
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr
Speaker if I know that hb3 78 only
requires the payment of earned unused
time when it's due to a layoff a
business closure or the sale of a
business and further if I know that
these circumstances are beyond the
control of the employee who as a result
has no opportunity to request the use of
that earned time would I now press the
red button to overturn the itl motion so
another motion might be made thank you
chair recognize represent a proud for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that this bill would
add new burdens on businesses and if I
know that the one-size fits-all model
for vacation time earn time and sick
time envisioned by this bill does not
comport with the actual practices of
many businesses forcing them to change
their policies in reaction to this
law and if I also know this law would
encourage businesses to adopt policies
unfavorable to the employees to protect
themselves and if I know that existing
law allows the Department of Labor to
investigate alleged violation of
vacation time policies and take
enforcement action making this law
unnecessary in most cases would I now
bill and motion before us is the
majority committee report of
inexperience to legisl and House Bill
378 this is a roll call vote all members
need to be in their seats if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you oppose you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
e
[Music]
represent
Hill all members present had an
opportunity to vote house Lieutenant
193 voting a 169 voting a committee
adopted majority committee on labor
industrial and re rehabilitative
services to which was referred House
Bill 542 FN act relative to weekly
benefit amounts for unemployment
compensation having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate mror Michael grer for the
committee minority of the committee have
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following Amendment and the
recommendation to Bill Auto pass with
Amendment for what reason does a member
rise I'd like to make a motion Mr
Speaker State your motion I'd like to
table a HB
542 that is a correct motion the motion
542 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I suppose nay the
eyes have it and the house bill 542 is
majority committee on labor industrial
and rehabilitative services to which was
referred House Bill 744 FN relative to
workers compensation andem any benefits
packet percentage considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolv that is inexpedient to
legislate Senator Mark Warden for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having been considered the same being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the following Amendment a
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment Sen Mark McKenzie
from the minority of the
committee for what reason does a member
rise to make a motion Mr Speaker State
your motion I'd like to table HB 744 it
is a proper motion the motion before us
is a table House Bill
744 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I iose nay the eyes
have it and House Bill 744 is laid on
on
de majority committee on Municipal and
County government to which was referred
House Bill
425 an act allowing Tamp tax exempt
entities to keep their tax exempt status
while renting facilities property to
entities that share their commission
consider the same report the same with a
recommendation the bill ought to pass
Senator Linda France for the majority of
the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to
legislate the bill is on second reading
open to further Amendment representative
Mark Pearson offers floor Amendment
0633 H it's in your seat Pockets chair
Pearson thank you Mr
Speaker The Minority Report on the
committee on this bill pointed to some
language in the original Bill my
original bill that would place an
unreasonable burden on assessors who may
lack the necessary time or
expertise I agree and so the amendment
before you takes out that whole
paragraph it is a bit convoluted it is a
bit Technical and I had a good talk with
myself I should write better language
than that so with the passage of the
amendment we're down to one very simple
thing until maybe 70 years ago most
churches had parsonages or rectories or
vicarages right next to the church
that's where the clergy member lived and
everybody knew you don't tax that
property it's part of the
church well along the way people started
uh having some second thoughts about the
wisdom of this for example the clergy
member lives in this
property until retirement but there's no
equity built up and secondly what if the
clergy family want to paint the bedroom
green but the church committee who owns
the building wants to paint it purple
what was birthed at that point was
called a housing allowance you take the
equivalent of living there utilities and
so on and make a payment to the clergy
member who can then go work to buy a
property of his or her own it'll be
their home they can design it the way
they want and what the housing allowance
will do is help the mortgage payments it
will help the utilities and it will pay
property
tax well what do you do with the old
parsonage
a lot of churches rented it out and they
took the money from that rental and used
it for the clergy housing
allowance the parsonage even though it's
rented out is real estate taxfree as
been well that was the arrangement
that's what I've known in places where
I've lived that's where lots of my
colleagues know in different states
across the political color spectrum
but why this bill two or three years ago
there was a court case in New Hampshire
it's arguable that a certain Church
owned a lot of property and they got a
lot of money for it and they claim they
didn't have to pay real estate tax on
any of that well that's not fair the
second wealthiest religious organization
in the world is Trinity Episcopal Church
Wall Street they own the buildings on
Wall Street and they pay massive real
estate taxes because that isn't their
mission that's just
income so with overreach a town
complained the church fought back the
court said no the town is right and I
would agree so since then different
towns across the state have hired
organizations to say help us take a look
at the whole real estate tax exempt
structure and different decisions were
made I get a real estate tax bill I had
to pay it was refunded but along the way
there was
confusion so a numbers of churches and
numbers of towns have said to me why
don't we put in law what had previously
been a an agreement that everybody
understood the amendment strips out all
the confusing language I wrote and
rental
policy that does what had been done for
Speaker the motion before us is the
Pearson floor Amendment
06338 are you ready for the question on
the amendment all those in favor say I I
oppose
[Applause]
nayis division has been called members
take
room if you weren't in the room can't
the motion before us is a clarification
vote on the
motion the floor
Amendment if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you oppose
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
[Music]
repr
represent all members present have an
opportunity to vote hous will attendance
vote 119 voting a 225 voting the
amendment
fails the motion before us now is a
majority committee report of ought to
pass for what reason it member rise Mr
Speaker I move to table HB
425 okay the motion is to table House
motion are you ready for the
question a division has been requested
the motion before us is the table House
Bill
425 this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you oppose you'll press the red button
[Music]
representative
Hall all members present had an
opportunity to vote houseold attend to
state to the
House Bill
table majority the committee on
Municipal and County government to which
was referred House Bill 6 17 and act
relative to the homestead right having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment the
recommendation the bill ought to pass
with Amendment s of Denise Murphy for
the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the following resolution that is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Laurel stavis for the minority of the
committee the amendment is
0437 H printed in house record 14 page
56 are you ready for the question
question on the amendment all those in
favor say
I call Nay the eyes have it the
amendment is adopted the motion before
us now is ought to pass with Amendment
the chair recognizes
stavis thank you Mr
Speaker I Rise an opposition to the
committee recommendation of about to
pass as amended on HB
617 bill that seeks to raise the allowed
amount of New Hampshire's homestead
exemption first I want to say that I
believe this exemption badly needs to be
raised given the rate of increase in
home values in New Hampshire it's time
we provided more relief for homeowners
in dire Financial Straits who seek
relief from
creditors and had the bill proposed to
raise the exemption from its current
rate of
120,000 to 150,000
even
175,000 or more for individuals and
twice that amount for married couples I
can say with some degree of certainty
that it would have sailed through our
committee with the unanimous ought to
pass a
vote but for reasons many of us couldn't
understand HB 617 seeks to raise the
number almost
tenfold to a whopping $1
million at the same time time the bill
adds IL defined language to the
homestead statute by including several
types of housing that would lead
confusion dispute and inevitably legal
challenges a homestead exemption is
meant to keep families in their homes
while they're navigating tough Financial
Times it's a provision that helps
prevent people from going from Bad
economic circumstances to an unmitigated
disaster and that's a good thing it
would also be a good thing to
re-evaluate the amount allowable under
the exemption from time to time so that
homeowners and creditors alike could be
sure that those amounts reflect fair
market values as economic conditions
change but the current median price of a
single family home in New Hampshire is
around
$500,000 and The Proposal that HB 6177
puts forward to increase the potential
exemption to twice that amount and 10
times what it is right now is just plain
extravagant unjustified by the numbers
and unworkable because of its confusing
language I urge you to vote no on the
committee recommendation of ought to
pass as amended so that another motion
can be made and another proposal
more informed by the facts can be
brought forward thank you Mr Speaker and
I request a division vote J recognize
representative
Murphy chair recognized representative
Litchfield thank you Mr
Speaker I I would like to begin by
saying I would like to request a roll
call vote on this bill if I could please
is it okay to start with
that do I have to wait okay
stop so this bill is actually a
bipartisan bill or I thought it was a
bipartisan Bill uh it was brought to me
by a constituent um that typically is
conservative and then a second
constituent brought it to me who is
actually liberal this bill is already on
the books this law is already on the B
books as we've already heard
it covers a home value of up to
$120,000 the problem is that that does
not is not up to date with the current
market values of homes in the state of
New Hampshire and I do understand what
what we're saying that the median value
may be around
500,000 but in doing my research there
it's it's a vast State there are
different Pockets with different home
values so I just want to give you a
couple of examples um my particular
District uh the median sales price is
$845,000
Atkinson
$1,347 th000 Windam 800,000 Alton
$785,000
um and then let me see I'll just do at
ringe
$889,000 so the point of this law and it
is out there I've researched all 50
states many states have it many of them
leave the value of the home unlimited it
does not debt it does not cancel debt
the problem is these days with the civil
suits at one point in time they would go
after your insurance if there was an
incident nowadays they're going after
your home so I had an attorney that came
to me and he said to me look I have two
cases one that happened a year ago and
one that's currently pending one was a
ski accident purely an accident he said
from the outside looking in you can tell
it it
inadvertent someone was injured were
hurt they did not feel that the
insurance money was enough so they went
after this person's home the person
almost lost their home um they mentioned
another person where it was the same
idea it was a car accident and they
didn't feel that the car insurance
covered enough and they wanted to go
after the person's home you still owe
the debt I went through all 50 states
and I put bumpers in I tried to cover
and the reason why it's so detailed is I
tried to be as comprehensive as I I
could so you still have to pay your
mortgage right um you could lose your
house if you don't pay your mortgage you
could lose your house if you don't pay
your property taxes if you don't pay
your bail bond you could still lose your
house okay um this is again just to
protect people from civil
suits and I think that's about it I'm
just simply saying that it's not staying
up with the current law so what I would
ask you to please pass this ought to
pass with the amendment and press the
green button and I would like to request
please Senate witfield has ask for a
roll call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
that's
the motion before us the majority
committee report of AO pass as amended
this is a roll call vote chair
recognized representative magaly for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that everyone who
testified and all of the written
testimony that the committee received on
this bill agreed that a million dollars
is too high and not the right
number Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill has confusing language
including what would happen with common
areas in homeowners
associations and condo associations
relative to the value of your house then
Mr Speaker would I vote no on this on
this bill so that a better motion can be
made thank you Mr Speaker chair
recognized representative John McDonald
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that the
current New Hampshire Homestead statue
allows for a
$120,000 homestead exemption to protect
the family's home Mr Mr Speaker if I
further know that the value of an
average single family home in many
hampire communities is now or is soared
to
$52,500 a 12.9% increase from January of
2024 lastly Mr Speaker if I know that
our families deserve to be protected
from attachments or levies on their
homes because of medical bills or other
deps directly resulting from terminal or
Copic Copic injury or illness if I know
know all this Mr Speaker you should now
vote Yes and press the green
button motion before us a majority
committer report of Auto pass am as on
Amendment as amended on House Bill 617
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you oppos your press the red button
[Music]
all members present had the opportunity
to vote also attendance state to the
vote 216 voting a 146 voting a committee
division Committee on Public Works and
highways to which was referred House
Bill 578 FN we have a division vote
coming right up so stay in your
seats an act directing a sound barrier
along the Fe return Pike having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate senat Martin
Jack for the committee this is a
the motion before us is inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 578 FN this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you press the red button voting stations
[Music]
all members had an opportunity to vote
house will attend to stay to the vote
338 voting a 25 voting a committee
adopted Committee on Public Works and
highways to which was referred House
Bill 713 FN act relative to mile markers
along Route 112 consider the same report
the same with a recommendation the bill
ought to pass representative Bill Boyd
for the committee are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
close nay the eyes have it the committee
[Music]
finance committee on resources
Recreation and development to which was
referred House Bill 607 FN act relative
to funding the Hampton Beach area
commission and making Appropriations
therefore we considered the same report
the same with a recommendation that the
bill ought to pass pres of Nicholas
Bridle for the committee are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I I those oppose nay the eyes have it
committee you eyes have it the committee
finance committee on resources
Recreation development to which was
referred House Bill 624 FNA an act
establishing a local River Management
advisory committee grant program and
making an appropriation therefore having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment and the
recommendation to Bill ought to pass
with Amendment sen of Allison NAB for
the committee the amendment is 0368 H
printed in house record 14 page 56 are
you ready for the question on the
I I guess I'm sorry I didn't hear it
somebody requested a
division on the
amendment this is a division vote
the motion before us is the amendment
H this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're oppose you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members pres had an opportunity to
vote how attend to stay the
vote 296 voting aay 67 voting aay the
amendment is adopted the motion before
us now is ought to pass with Amendment
are you ready for the question all those
division the motion before the vote the
member has requested a division it will
the motion before us is autop pass with
Amendment on House Bill 624 FNA this is
a division vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
oppos you'll press the red button voting
[Music]
repres
suan while members present had an
opportunity to vote also attend to stay
the
vote 264 voting aay 100 voting aay the
committee report is
the committee on science technology and
energy to which was referred House Bill
224 FN act relative to rebates to rate
payers from the renewable energy fund
and considered the same report the same
with the following Amendment and
recommendation the bill aut to pass with
Amendment representative Janine n for
the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution result that is
inexpedient to legislate sen of cat
McGee for the minority of the committee
the amendment is
0288 H printed in house record 14 pages
47- 48 are you record ready for the
question on the amendment all those in
favor say I I IE oppose nay the eyes
have it and the amendment is adopted the
motion before us now is ought to pass
with Amendment the chair recognize
thank you Mr Speaker this bill is about
something called the renewable energy
fund what is that it is a dedicated
non-aps fund it's funded by the
utilities when they fall short of the
goals of the renewable portfolio
standard by Statute the renewable energy
fund is intended to support guess what
renewable energy
initiatives this bill would reallocate
the renewable energy fund including
rebates to rate paays that sounds pretty
good but I'm going to give you three
good reasons to vote against this
bill any one of these three should be
enough to get you to press the red
button but I'm going to give you all
three number one because it's a
dedicated non-aps fund that's not what's
supposed to happen to it it's not
supposed to be reallocated that it's
supposed to be used for the purpose that
it's intended for the current balance is
$10 million and the bill would make 100%
of these funds go to purposes that the
fund was not intended for not only that
this is a really good use of money every
dollar that's invested from the
renewable energy fund actually generates
$8 of private investment that is a
pretty darn good leverage I'd say we've
seen $416 million
in private investment from the renewable
energy fund program to date moreover
remember that renewable energy keeps
money in the state on the other hand
every dollar that we spend on fossil
fuels is a dollar going to Texas
Louisiana Oklahoma not staying in the
state so that's number one number two if
you look at the bill it's unclear how
these funds would get red distributed
the bill says that the funds go to
administrative costs to the office of
offshore wind and energy Innovation and
incentive payments and whatever is left
over that's what goes to the rate payer
rebates the bill doesn't say how these
things get distributed and I have no
idea what incentive payments are that is
just
undefined so what does this work out to
well I looked at my December 2024 bill
from Liber utilities which by a bill
that we passed a couple of years ago
tells us how much we paid into the
renewable uh energy fund or actually the
cost of RPS compliance renewable
portfolio standard compliance in
20123 the average rate payer spent
$24.75 for the year on compliance with
the renewable portfolio standard only
some of that went into the renewable
energy fund so when you take out the
administrative costs funding the office
of offshore wind and energy Innovation
and whatever incentive payments are I
have no
idea what's left over as a rebate for
the average customer would end up buying
about one latte from Starbucks per year
so if you think it's a really good idea
to tell your constituents yeah I decided
to keep money uh flowing to Texas and
Oklahoma for fossil fuels so you could
have one latte from Starbucks this year
go for
it final thing number three and this is
the best one if you look at the trailer
bill
hb2 and I refer you to page 73 section
188 of the bill it says that it's going
to sweep the $10 million that are in the
renewable energy fund into the general
fund
so which is it are we going to use the
renewable energy fund to sweep into the
general fund are we going to have it go
to the rate payers and these other
purposes it can't be both it seems that
someone's left hand doesn't know what
someone's right hand is doing so this is
just a plain bad Bill I've given you
three good reasons to vote against it so
I ask you to press the red button on the
motion three times and Mr Speaker I
request a roll call
n thank you Mr Speaker I rise in support
of the ought toach Mo motion on House
Bill
224 I sponsored this bill to help lower
energy costs we can do that by rebating
most of the renewable energy fund back
to rate payers saving between 2. 5 and
$7.3 million a year we have some of the
highest energy costs in the country we
saw an example of the impact of these
high electricity prices just last week
where on Friday the New Hampshire
Electric Co-op announced another rate
hike meaning they have increased their
rates by more than 6% since
December Granite Staters need relief
from higher energy costs now and this
bill offers them that rebating fund
funds back to rate payers Is Not A New
Concept we have been rebating funds from
the regional greenhouse gas initiative
Reggie for 13 years and that has saved
rate payers hundreds of millions of
dollars over that time frame if that
legislation didn't go through we would
be paying even higher costs now than we
already are those opposed to the bill
want the subsidies to continue subsidy
programs help some but it's at the
expense of others which is unfortunate
as amended HP 224 will exempt administra
administrative costs and funding for the
office of energy Innovation rebate ourf
money to rate payers and lower energy
costs I ask the body to support the op
to pass motion on House Bill 224 by
pressing the green button thank you Mr
Speaker representative Corman as
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
remind
C the motion before us majority
committee report of aut passes amended
on House Bill 224 this is a roll call
vote chair recognized representative
Speaker if I knew the renewable energy
fund incentivizes critical renewable
energy projects in New Hampshire with
nearly eight times the amount spent from
the fund Amplified by private
funding and if I knew that Granite
Staters were their primary beneficiaries
of the renewable energy and economic
Investments this
creates and if I knew that this bill
would undermine the integrity and
availability of those fund reserves by
shifting them to purposes that may have
nothing to do with renewable
energy then would I press the red button
to defeat this bill so another motion
can be
made chair recognize representative n
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that the granite state suffers from
extremely high energy costs and if I
know that this bill will help alleviate
some of the suffering by rebating funds
back to the rate payers would I then
press the green button to pass house
Bill 224 thank you Mr Speaker motion
before as a majority committee report of
Auto passes amended and House Bill 224
Mr roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press a green button if you're
opposed you'll press a red button voting
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
vote 200 voting a 160t a the committee
report is adopted and it goes to Ways
and
Means majority of committee on science
technology and energy to which was
referred House Bill 654 FN an act
relative to owing small customer
generators in the ability to participate
in group net metering consider the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate sen JD Bernardi for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass representative Thomas Corman for
the minority of the
committee the
motion for what reason does a member
rise uh to Place HB 654 on the table
please okay that is a correct motion the
motion is to lay House Bill 654 FN on
the
table are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those oppose nay
the eyes have it and House Bill 654 is
table for what reason does a member rise
Mr Speaker after consultation with the
ranking member on my committee I move to
special order House Bill 723 to the next
order of business and would like to
speak to my motion
you you may speak to your motion so the
next two bills 681 and 723 deal with the
same topic but 723 is the higher
priority bill so we would like to take
that up next and would appreciate the
Indulgence of the members to vote to
move that bill to the next order of
business thank you Mr Speaker the mo the
motion before us is to special order
House Bill 723 to the next order of
business are you ready for the question
all those in favor say
majority committee on science technology
and energy to which was referred House
Bill 723 FN act repealing the multi-use
energy data platform having considered
the same report the same with the
following recommendation that the bill
ought to pass representative Lex Berne
for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate of cat McGee
from the minority of the committee Jer
McGee thank you Mr Speaker and good
afternoon esteemed
colleagues uh I I rise in opposition to
killing the Statewide energy data
platform a project initiated by the
state to save people money right before
we find out just how much money can be
saved by Granite Staters if we build it
for my fellow members of the emerging
Technologies caucus making energy data
accessible is very popular right now
it's a big thing in the United States
and around the world because of the
money saving abilities you have when you
unlock that
data Governor sununu signed SB 284 into
law in
2019 it compelled the state's Electric
and Gas Utilities to to work together
along with the New Hampshire energy
stakeholders and even experts from
around the country who were very
interested in this Innovative
project um and they set up a docket uh
at the Public Utilities Commission or
pu their task was to create secure
automated access to New Hampshire's
electric and gas data so that we can
plan for and create cost savings on
energy throughout the
state we were not the first state to try
this we had examples from states that
were early adopters like Texas and
Illinois and New York before us all who
got a handle on their energy data in
order to find savings and create
Innovations in the free
market many other states are in various
stages of doing the same thing and
harnessing energy data is not that
unusual around the world but many
Outsiders looking into our pu docket
were intrigued by the New Hampshire
collaboration it was fruitful we learned
from other states we applied what we
learned and we designed uh a tool that
would benefit from that
knowledge we talked a lot about
Innovation and free markets on our
committee we talk about saving people
money a lot in the house and we have
certainly spent time telling people we
are going to save them money on their
energy
bills well here's our
chance the bill required the utilities
to run a project uh by forming a
governance Council of stakeholders
including the department of energy uh
this group includes it professionals
from the utilities who have spent years
pursuing something they never would have
without the state's
prompting they gave up control of their
individual ual data in order to support
this
project and you know what since the
prime sponsor of the bill had absolutely
no knowledge of this project before he
filed the bill I'm thinking maybe some
of them still don't want to give up
their
data but data access is a gateway uh to
information and that information unlocks
all kinds of innovation in the free
market and you can't manage what you
can't measure
so what does the New Hampshire data Hub
do automating all our energy data in one
place can give individuals a way to
figure out the cheapest way to lower
their energy
bills it can help energy competitors
bring greater efficiencies to businesses
or facilities managers uh can get
accurate pictures of the energy use of
their entire building complex they can't
do that today uh or how about
municipalities who want an analysis of
their gas and electric use so that they
can cut energy costs and pass those
savings on to
taxpayers the New Hampshire data data
Hub is a game
Cher but only if we defeat this effort
to kill it before the cost benefit
analysis is completed this
fall and if the conclusion of the cost
benefit analysis isn't significant cost
savings for granite Staters then the
project will be rejected based upon its
merits over at the Public Utilities
Commission so there is already a process
to kill this project if in any way it
comes back not being a cost savings to
the rate payers able to unlock a lot of
savings so if that cost benefit analysis
doesn't pencil out then the project will
be canceled with the knowledge that we
were wrong about the savings that we
could bring to rate payers but today we
have no proof we have no proof of the
cost and we have no proof of the
benefits and the guesstimate that makes
up the fiscal note admits that the
actual costs are unknown and there is no
offer of an assessment of any of the
benefits of which there are many um
according to a national energy
consulting firm called dunsky who did a
preliminary New Hampshire based analysis
they concluded that residential rate
payers will realize most of the savings
from the New Hampshire data Hub um and
those savings are in the tens of
millions but they can't give us an
actual cost benefit until till the price
is in on what it'll cost us to build it
and then what those benefits will be I
ask that you push the red button to stop
the sabotage of a project that we the
state pursued in order to save people
money on their energy bills something we
keep saying we're doing and now you can
point to something and say we are doing
that uh nothing is gained by killing
this project here today before we know
what we are about to lose um please vote
red for your constituents and Mr Speaker
I ask that we um I request a roll call
vote
Bry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker one
of the core functions of the New
Hampshire Public Utilities Commission
the Pu is to evaluate and then approve
or deny proposals by regulated utilities
for for Capital Improvements when a u
utility wants to upgrade equipment or
software they must justify the associate
expenses to the PVC an integral part of
this justification is to show that the
improvements will be coste effective and
provide benefits to their
customers for example Unitil
successfully went through this process
some years ago to upgrade all of their
customers electric meters and to build a
data platform and an app where customers
can monitor their own electric use usage
the current process is well established
and
effective the subject of this bill the
Statewide multi-use energy data platform
law flips that process on its head it
mandates that the department of energy
and the utilities build a centralized
Statewide data platform and at the same
time also mandates that the project
should be deferred if the cost is
unreasonable or not in the public
interest it is a bit like a Perpetual
contradiction machine the project is
bylaw mandated to go forward but also
bylaw mandated to be deferred if not in
the public interest as you might imagine
this has led to a situation where
resources are continuously spent by the
department of energy the utilities and
other Brokers to move this
along but in the six years since this
mandate was passed no code has been
written and no software
procured over the years two federal
grants were sought and all were rejected
by the Biden administ ministration which
I'd argue was generally supportive of
such infrastructure projects some of the
reasons for rejection included quote
does not adequately build a case that
the proposed project will lead to
proposed benefits and quote the project
impact may be
unrealistic and quote does not justify
the Project's economic
viability so to reiterate the previous
green energy Administration which was
not shy in spending on these kinds of
projects deemed this project is not does
not have economic
viability proponents will argue that the
benefits are clear and that after 6
years only the cost is still unknown
let's validate some of that argument on
cost we have some hints utilities have
estimated $4.5 to7 million just in their
own cost to Simply connect to this data
platform you can reasonably extrapolate
from this that the platform itself will
be significantly more than the
connection cost probably in the tens of
millions of dollars the benefits
argument comes from a report by the
dunsky corporation and it only covers
customers accessing their own usage data
like the Unitil example I gave earlier
but the Unitil solution was built and
operates today without the Statewide
data platform therefore the argued
benefits can already be achieved and are
being achieved without this platform
but maybe there are other benefits we
just haven't discovered yet a colleague
in committee suggested quote why not
just build it and then see if there are
any
benefits I actually agree with that
sentiment this is what software startups
do all the time sometimes they build
valuable and beneficial products but
most of the time they end up failing
Tech Innovation is not easy or
straightforward it's best left to
entrepreneurs to Risk Takers and the
free market not to estate government
bureaucracy the role of government is to
Res is to be responsible stewards of
public resources the government should
stick to buying reliable and proven
software with clear benefits especially
when it comes to our energy
grid so is the Statewide data platform
beneficial maybe maybe not but after six
years of trying to get this project off
the ground perhaps it's time to cut our
losses the department of energy would be
the biggest benefactor of this project
because it would give them a view of the
Statewide energy usage and yet they
testify that they are neutral on this
bill if they don't need this platform
and utilities can already meet their
customer needs with their own data
platforms then let's repeal this mandate
and save some money vote green thank you
Mr
Speaker representative McGee has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded you need to stand
up it is sufficiently seconded this will
the motion before us is ought to pass on
house buillt
723 this is going to be a roll call vote
chair recognize representative McGee for
a parliamentary
if I know that rate payers lose if we
kill this project before we secure the
cost benefit analysis that we have been
working towards for quite some
time and if I know that there is a
process in place for that decision to be
made at the Public Utilities Commission
and so we do not have to kill it here
today if I know that in an Information
Age unlocking data invites innovators to
create solutions that are not available
today to help us save
money but the New Hampshire data Hub has
tangible ways to save people money
without those future future savings that
we haven't identified yet and finally if
I know that together we can overturn the
OTP and move on to an itl so that the
New Hampshire this New Hampshire Tech
project uh that we could all be proud of
uh is not derailed today at the 11th
hour after a lot of work has been put in
by all of the parties involved D then
would I now press the red button to
thank those who did this work and let
them uh and give them a chance to prove
that they can bring Energy savings to
Granite the granite state thank
you chair calls representative Doug
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know if I know it's been six years
since this bill was enacted and nothing
has been built yet if I also know that
this bill circumvents the normal cost
benefit justification process and if I
know the benefits are still unclear and
that the installation costs alone are
between $4.5 and7
million uh and God knows how much more
then Mr Speaker would I then press the
green button and repeal this Bill thank
you Mr Speaker the motion before us is
aut the majority committee report of
autop paath on House Bill 723 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're oppos
you'll press the red button voting
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
to vote I'll tend to stay the
vote 2011 voting aay 160 voting aay
committee report is adopted and it is
majority the committee on science
technology and energy to which was
referred House Bill 681 FN an act
establishing a Statewide online energy
data platform having considered the same
report the same with a following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate representative Lex bares
for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with a
recommendation the bill ought to pass
representative Thomas Corman for the
minority of the
committee are you ready for the
question on the motion of inexpedient to
legislate all those in favor say I iose
nay eyes have it and the committee
adopted majority of the committee on
state and federal relations and Veterans
Affairs to which was referred hcr1
n calling for policy makers locally and
nationally to fully consider all
relevant information and factors
pertaining to climate change before
pursuing courses of action that could
adversely affect any economy or
environment and considered the same
report the same with a recommendation
that bill ought to pass sen Michael
Moffett from the minor majority of the
committee minority of the
committee having considered the same
being unable to agree with the majority
Report with the following resolution
resolve that is in media to legislate
representative Christine Sebert for the
minority of the committee the chair
Speaker all right thank you Mr Speaker
at first glance hcr1 appears benign and
in all honesty it sounds like a good
smart and fair measure to
have yet the title is deceiving and the
true intent is the exact opposite many
of us intend attend hearings listen to
all listen and read to all testimony the
text provides only baseless accusations
with no reliable evidence to back it up
none of us need made a
resolution that prematurely assigns
intent on our behalf On Any Given issue
each piece of legislation is unique and
deserves to be looked at objectively in
the time by the through since the time
of its Inception in an August Granite
State poll 41% of Republicans ages 18 to
34 said climate change was human cost in
fact polling suggests that younger
voters of any age bracket regardless of
political party are prioritizing the
environment in climate change when it
comes to their views on climate
two-thirds of younger Republicans
acknowledge that human activity
contributes to climate change there
comes a point where evidence is truly
overwhelming and hard to ignore hcr1 is
nothing more than a last ditch attempt
to have the last word when your argument
is a losing one thank
Moffett thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker this resolution
simply calls for all voices to be heard
as we develop climate
policy bill has been public the
committee reports are public you can
read those so why is this important that
all voices be heard well climate
alarmists and extremists have long been
very successful in defining the climate
narrative on their
terms hysterical claims abound I won't
go through them you've heard a lot of
them and we're constantly told there's a
climate
consensus among scientists but in 2023 a
list of
169 scientists Scholars and others this
list was released and these folks said
quote there is no climate emergency
unquote of particular interest to our
state federal and veterans committee
were efforts to force our
military to military aircraft to use
biofuel which is much more expensive
it's more climate friendly but much more
expensive and it's problematical for for
uh air Air Force and and Aviation for
folks or to mandate battery powered
tactical
Vehicles so when the climate crae
threatens National Security we need to
take notice California even as you
probably heard California has even
passed a law Banning the sale of gas
powerered cars in 10 years
2035 many want New Hampshire to
follow next door in Vermont lawmakers uh
did some really radical climate leg
legislating two years
ago people want New Hampshire to follow
suit in Vermont they want the energy
companies to pay to pay big time for
changing Vermont's
climate so here in this body or in any
legislative body we often asked to
impose higher electric rates as the
folks in Science and Tech know so well
to subsidize questionable climate
initiatives fortunately we've been able
to resist much of that
pressure but here in New Hampshire not
so long ago in this very body a bill
came to the to this body to Outlaw to
ban wood stoves in New Hampshire I'm
from Coos County and from gron we had a
wood stove we had a wood my dad put it
in a wood
furnace so the movement to take away
wood stoves or or furnaces and that type
of thing of which there are so many
proposals and
ideas uh especially like in
schools and the flip side of those argu
are hard to get out
there then there are the carbon credit
or carbon allowance
issues the United Nations assigns carbon
credit formulas to various countries who
are supposed to monitor carbon emissions
and report back to the UN organizations
can buy or sell carbon credits 13 states
many of our neighbors are involved in
cap and trade I would submit that such
programs have zero impact on our climate
but they do make electric rat rates
higher and many climate activists as
you've heard fly around the world in in
Jets now they leave massive carbon
Footprints so to counter that they plant
trees to offset their carbon use or or
they buy Forest they plant trees to buy
forest and why does that matter to us
well out of state entity purchases in
Coos County they purchased 146,000 Acres
of Forest in Coos County my home my
original home county to engage carbon
offsets and even sell carbon credits so
they've taken the forest land up north
and it's it's no longer available for
Tim Timber use it's for carbon credits
and carbon
offsets so it's hard to raise awareness
about the dangers of climate extremism
when the media the so-called clean
energy Industries lawmakers academics
and alarmists control the
narrative when they join Force and when
they qu when people like
me
question the extent of of man's impact
on climate uh we get called deniers so
let's stop bullying people who are
skeptical of some of the climate claims
the the this resolution simply calls for
all voices to be heard and I'll close
with a personal example some of you know
that I I do opinion pieces I write I had
something in today's union leader for
example but when I write about climate I
can't often times I'll I'll try to
counter some climate perspective with a
different climate perspective and I
can't get it published as as a personal
example and yet a 15-year-old Swedish
activist and Greta Thum got to address
the United Nations so that's the type of
thing we're talking about or or AOC was
the head of the green New Deal she was a
a bartender so to finish
also be in order to finish we do we
don't want to see good people being
bullied threatened or or called deniers
or worse if they have concerns about
dubious climate policies so let's let's
just let all voices be heard thank you
Mr
Speaker the motion before us is a
majority committer report of Auto pass
on
hcr1 are you ready for the question
the division has been requested members
seats who requested the roll
call General Granger requests the roll
call is that sufficiently
seconded oh sorry it is sufficiently
the motion before us is the majority
committer report of Auto pass on
hcr1 this is a roll call vote chair
recognize representative seabird for a
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that this measure does a disservice
to everyone here by assigning blame and
intent without allowing for the proper
process to take place in an unbiased way
and if I know that divisiveness is
already rampant in this body and adding
to the pile is irresponsible to everyone
in the state of New Hampshire and
finally Mr Speaker that everyone is
anxious for us to hand the floor over to
the the transportation
committee then would I please press the
red button so that we may bring forward
a motion to be voted on in a Voice vote
in the name of personal sovereignty
thank you chair recognize representative
court thank you again Mr Speaker Mr
Speaker if I know that climate extremism
is scaring the heck out of our children
and if I know that some folks are
ridiculed and they have their views
suppressed if they challenge climate
alarmism and if I don't want New
Hampshire to follow the entrace of other
states where lawmakers have been bullied
into passing dubious climate laws and
finally if I know that we should promote
a A diversity of opinion regarding
climate and that we should
offer uh Equity of media access to all
opinions as well as inclusion of climate
perspectives as we develop laws and
policies where I then press the the
ironically colored green button to pass
this resolution and call for all voices
to be
heard the motion before us
order the motion before us majority
committee report of Auto pass on
hcr1 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you oppose you press the red button
voting stations were open for 30
[Music]
all members pres have an opportunity to
vote house will tend to say the
vote 197 voting a 156 voting a committee
adopted wending on transportation to
which was referred House Bill 305 an act
relative to speed and red light cameras
for traffic enforcement get the CED the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolve that is inexpedient
to legislate s Henry Geon for the
committee are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I nay the eyes
adopted majority committee on
transportation to which was referred
House Bill
419 enact relative Ana requiring vehicle
headlights to be on when windshield
wipers are also on considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that as inexpedient
to legislate sen Matthew pataro for the
majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass from Miss Mark padon for the
minority of the committee the chair
recognizes
thank you Mr chair I
EXC you know what I meant Mr speaker
thank you Mr Speaker and Mr speaker
thank you so much for not calling me up
after the circumcision issue because uh
uh full disclosure I had it done as a
baby and I cried my eyes
out just you know I wasn't happy to have
this the only time my life I wasn't
happy to have 10 cents
this is this is a an issue of what eight
18 other states
do they have when your wind your wipers
are on you should have your headlights
on now we all come from uh we call come
from areas that have these two-lane
roads winding through the hills they
they go up and down they go
around and your grandma is uh riding
down this
road coming the other way is is an
tractor now they're getting closer and
closer and now there's driving rain that
we're used to in uh New Hampshire you
know in New Hampshire they say if you
don't like the weather just wait a
minute that being said they're getting
closer her wipers are on they get to 900
ft if her lights are on they would have
saw each other but they
don't they get to 700 F feet they still
don't see each other they get to 400
feet they don't see each other at 100 ft
they finally see each other but it's too
late to
Deere as I
say 18
states have this including our New
England neighbors of Connecticut Maine
Island there was a there was a study
done for uh daytime use of Automotive
headlamps storing inclement
weather was conducted by the lighting
research center of the renier Poly
Technical Institute one of the leading
engineering schools in the in the
country
and they
compared data from seven
states and in that data what they looked
at was a defined time before and after
they passed these
statutes and what they found
was the results showed that there was a
7% deduction in fatal
accidents during daytime inclement
weather and a third 30%
deduction in in fatal accidents during
Dusk and
reduction now we all
have people on the roads that we love
people we have families we have loved
ones we have friends and we have
constituents we're giving you the chance
right now to lower their chance F
fertility by 7% and
30% I think we should press the red
button and help grandma get down the
gki thank you Mr
Speaker I rise in support of the
committee's motion of itl for two
reasons number one the majority already
felt most Vehicles already have
Daylights on daylight lights on their
car and in terms of the wipers working
during that time it makes this makes
this bill
mute second of all it adds more
responsibility for our unburdened law
enforcement now they become the wiper
police please press the green button
thank
you representative Granger has requested
a roll call is that sufficiently
seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
the motion before us in the majority
committee report of inexperience of
legisl on House Bill 419 this is a roll
call vote chair recognized
representative Jones for parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr
Speaker if I knew that all of us have
people we care about constituents we
care about loved ones we care about on
the road and if I knew we could decrease
the incident fatality by 7 to 30%
wouldn't I push the red
button chair recognize representative
thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that most
Vehicles manufactured nowadays their
headlights come on when the windsh
wipers come on because it usually gets
pretty dark Mr Speaker I also know if
you agree with this topic something like
this would be better addressed as a as a
education as a PSA or maybe even using
the digital programmable signs on the
side of the highways Mr Speaker if I
know that the people of this state
don't need any more frivolous reasons to
get pulled over on the side of the road
button the motion before us is a is a
majority committee report of inexpedient
to legisla and House Bill 419 this a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press a green button if you're oppos
you'll press a red button voting
[Music]
while members present had an opportunity
to vote also attend to stay to the
vote 277 227 voting a 2 129 voting a
committee on transportation to which was
referred House Bill 649 FN removing the
requirement for physical safety
inspections and onboard diagnostic test
for passenger vehicles and eliminating
funding for the motor vehicle air
pollution abatement fund this the house
will be in
order this comes without recommendation
representative Walt moves ought to pass
Speaker colleagues we heard significant
testimony throughout the period we heard
we all received I assume you all got
them all of those emails from all of our
constituents
frustrated by the inspection program we
know it is broken we know it needs to be
reworked we want to fix it this bill is
not the correct
fix we had the opportunity uh from the
author of the bill to work with them to
address many of the shortcomings we saw
in it uh or we had the offer we did not
have the opportunity we did not get the
time to work with them to resolve those
issues during the bill during the uh
process it was pushed to a vote and here
we
are most notably there's a significant
financial risk to the state the way this
bill is written we currently have an
agreement with the Department of
Transportation and the Environmental
Protection
Agency that leads if we come out of
compliance with an EPA mandate for
emissions testing we are putting as much
as $200 million a year in do funding at
risk I don't know if it'll happen I
don't know if the do will take it away I
don't know if the do will still exist
assum the EPA will still exist to take
it away but it is an unacceptable risk
at this point to not account for that
especially given our financial position
and therefore I encourage you to vote uh
against the ought to pass for this so
that have an opportunity to fix the bill
and make it work better for the granite
for thank you Mr
Speaker I come to before the body today
in support of House Bill
649 which would overturn the so-called
safety inspections on vehicles on public
roadways New Hampshire is one of only 10
states left that have a law such as this
40 states don't have it or have passed
to get rid of
it research has shown that there is not
a significant disparity in injury or
lethality accidents between states that
do and do not have inspections such as
this indeed there is no clear presence
of danger to the
public so I'll ask a question who is
responsible for the safe operation of
their motor vehicle the operator is the
owner
is there should not be a business of
supplementing Private Industry under
penalty of law and fines this is
especially true when this law or policy
is questioned based on ethics
transparency and equal
application in terms of ethics and
transparency while there is a reporting
method to report an impropriety or a
questionable inspection it's not known
by much of the public in fact there was
test only only 60 people had put in
complaints last year also if you want a
second opinion many shops will not
inspect a car that has been declined
somewhere else because they don't want
to be investigated for how they're doing
inspections as far as equal application
under law we've heard from voters of all
demographics they don't feel like it is
equally applied it disproportionately
affects the less financially secure and
I'll ask one other question do any any
of you know of any single woman or
elderly person who feels like they were
the
victim of predatory business practices
in the inspection
law the fact that this is possibly the
most unpopular law that exists in the
books of the State of New
Hampshire and has the public out crying
us uh for us to overturn it and move the
liability back to the owner and away
from the false sense of security of the
inspector should speak
volumes now also in speaking with the
members of the House Transportation
committee we've been trying to throw
guard rails on this for years now little
pun intended yes but as long as it
stands as it's passed under RSA 541a
which is allowed it to do its own rules
writing and expand its own program
without legislative uh without this
legislative
body you are no longer in control of
this law and you haven't been for a long
time so when the majority of our uh
constituents are begging us to overturn
this and when we know that we're no
longer in control of it I believe that
it is our duty to pass this and I hope
that you will join me in pressing the
green
button the motion before us is aut to
649 roll call has been requested is that
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 649 this is a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative Au for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that there's bipartisan
agreement that the State motor vehicle
safety inspection program needs reform
and if I know that when enacting that
reform we should be careful to avoid
unint unintended consequences like
eliminating the emissions program and
potentially causing problems with the
EPA by taking a scalpel to the program
rather than a sledgehammer and if I know
that the transportation committee
retained HB 209 a bill that be will be
worked on this summer and is a much
better scalpel than this bill would I
now press the red button to defeat the
itl motion so that another motion can be
made thank you J recognized
Representative Steven Smith for a
parliamentary
inquir Mr Speaker if you and my
colleagues who've been around for a
while recall seeing me for years stand
here and defend the inspection program
well if I know I can't do that anymore
because over those years I have tried to
get reasonable
reforms if I know that I put a Statute
in that said you can't be failed for
cosmetic rust cuz damn it you have the
right to drive an ugly vehicle in New
Hampshire and despite that the
department of safety and the shops have
ignored the statute which was effective
on passage and that today people are
still being failed for something that is
the law Mr Speaker if I know I've tried
to work with the industry and they have
stopped us at every single turn and I'm
mad as hell and I'm not going to take it
anymore into today I want to stick up
for my constituents then Mr Speaker
would I press the green button to send a
message that it's the people of New
Hampshire that I'm worried about
today house will house will be in
order the motion before us is a to pass
on House Bill
649 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press a green button if
you're oppos you'll press a red button
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attendance state of
the
order 212 re 143 nay committee report is
adopted representative Melvin and nter
vote
speak the last bill goes to Ways and
Means Committee on resources Recreation
we're on the bill removed from the
consent calendar committee on resources
Recreation development to which was
referred House Bill 691 FN act
prohibiting the addition of fluoridation
chemicals to Public Water Systems have
been considered the same report the same
with the following resolution resolved
that is inexpedient to legislate sen
POF uh Mr Speaker please oppose the
committee recommendation on this
bipartison bill the committee assessed
the towns can address public water FL
validation via a warrant article but the
committee did not realize that it is
immoral to bulk medicate the whole
population regardless of their personal
medical needs and regardless of their
individual
sensitivities on top of that last year
Biden's Health agencies finally
confirmed that fluorite is neurotoxic
and was lowering IQ for certain
populations
finally the committee did not know that
between the deliberation and now UT
legislature fully Advanced identical
legislation so we won't be the first to
vote for it so please vote ah to fight
against chronic disabilities bankrupting
thank you Mr
Speaker so the resources Recreation and
development committee heard broad
testimony both in support and opposition
regarding the science and health effects
of these chemicals in the water system
however the committee feels the issue
does not need additional Superfluous
State legislation as local communities
served by these Water Supplies have
local control and chose to add chemicals
their to their water supply they also
have the means to choose to remove these
chemicals from the Water Supplies as
well the committee feels that this issue
is about local control and the committee
recommends not adding additional
legislation where it isn't needed thank
Speaker representative Granger has
requested a roll call in
it representative po off has requested a
roll call and is sufficiently seconded
and it has been sufficiently seconded
members take your seats this will be a
the motion before us is inexpedient to
legisl on House Bill 691 this a roll
call vote chair
recognizes Diane Kelly for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that the safety of fluoride in water is
questionable and increasing research is
showing health risks like neurological
problems hypothyroidism osteoporosis and
cancer and if I know that the benefits
of water fluoridation can be obtained by
pills or topical fluoride treatments
such as toothpaste and rinses and if I
further know that informed consent
should be guaranteed for all individuals
so that they can decide for themselves
rather than some local governing body in
a low turnout election would I then
press the red button so that a better
motion can be made thank you chair
inquiry thank you Mr Mr Speaker Mr
Speaker if I know that the
municipalities had the local control and
local choice to add chemicals to their
water supply and thus the choice to them
them as well and if I know that 14 of
the 15 members of this committee voted
in favor to itl the motion for this
legislation as it's a local control
issue and does not need any further
legislation would I not press the green
button to cast my vote to itl this Bill
thank you the motion before us is any
speed to legislator and House Bill 691
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press a green button if
you're oppos press a red button voting
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
vote 190 voting a 156 voting a committee
report is adopted recogniz the cler
recognize the clerk
thank you Mr Speaker I have a note from
the chair of the committee on ways and
means uh Mr Speaker I wave off the
second committee referral of House Bill
chair recognize the member from Auburn
representative Osborne for a third
reading
motion think you resolve that the house
now adjourned from the early session
that the business of the late session be
in order at the present time that the
reading of bills be by title only and
resolutions by caption only and that all
bills ordered a third reading be read a
third time by this resolution and that
all titles of bills be the same as
adopted and that they be passed at the
present time and when the house adjourns
today it be to meet Thursday March 13th
at 10:00 a.m. question is on the third
reading motion are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppos nay the eyes have it the
adopted we have one announcement
representative
Iman thank you Mr Speaker emerging
Technologies caucus we have a field trip
tomorrow to energy Park in Manchester at
780 North Commercial Street we're going
to have a presentation in a tour it's a
secure facility so please contact me
before just showing up tomorrow thank
you we now want to request foran consent
gerana thank you Mr chair Mr Speaker I
did it already thank you Mr Speaker in
May of 2022 my son Dylan and I spent a
glorious afternoon being shown around
Munich by a young Ukrainian woman who
had moved to Germany as a teenager with
her parents after the tour over beer and
sour Bren she told us that her family
had finally prevailed in convincing her
grandparents to flee their War torn
country and join them in Germany they
left behind the only homes and only
communities they had ever known and they
left behind sons nephews and grandsons
Who Remain in Ukraine fighting for their
country's Freedom her parents understood
her grandparents understood that they
would likely never see their homes again
but even more devastatingly they knew
that they would likely never see those
loved ones again on a train from Berlin
headed west to Hanover we met dozens of
women and children Ukrainian refugees
carrying all of their Earthly
possessions with them but also the
mental and emotional baggage of the
trauma that will haunt their families
for
Generations February 24th marked three
years since the Russian invasion of
Ukraine launching the largest land war
in Europe since the second world
war from the very first moments of this
barbaric conflict Granite Staters have
shown unflagging dedication to the cause
of freedom for Ukraine giving money time
and energy to support the victims of
Russian aggression
two Grassroots organizations here in New
Hampshire have been hard at work
supporting Ukraine since the earliest
days of this barbaric conflict NH for
Ukraine and common main for Ukraine have
provided money food medical supplies and
Social Services to the victims of the
war in Poland and closer to the front in
Ukraine
itself Granite Staters feel a special
Affinity I think for ukrainians they
embody our motto Live Free or Die as we
Mark the third anniversary of this
tragic War let us recommit ourselves to
the cause of Freedom that we in New
Hampshire hold so dear Granite Staters
[Applause]
[Music]
committee
members one of my constituents had asked
me to come up here and request that we
put our emails back on the system so
that each one of the Committees members
would receive their individual emails so
Mr Speaker I would like to call that the
house acques to the request of the
petition and direct it to create a
unique email address for each standing
special and statutory committee that
delivers the emails to each member of
that particular committee thank
on thank you Mr Speaker I rise today day
to honor women's History Month in March
1911 a fire started inside the Triangle
shirt waist Factory in New York City and
as the 146 women working inside rushed
to exit they realized the doors were
locked to keep them inside and working
they all died these women silenced in
life spoke loudly in death leading to
Greater protection from workers this
tragedy also added to the momentum for
the women suffrage movement just 9 years
later women gained the right to vote we
gained our
voice while today we have our voice at
The Ballot Box and in the legislature
too often women still say silent out to
keep the Fe the keep the peace or out of
fear a woman forced to keep quiet in
potentially dangerous situations is
encouraged to become a victim through
inaction how often do we ask women to
speak out in cases of domestic abuse yet
they are still afraid that they will be
ignored so they suffer in
silence 105 years ago women gain the
right to vote some 140 of us in this
chamber have a strong voice to stand
vote and speak for those who elected us
when women are silenced it hurts all of
us we stand today at a pivotal moment
women who have been silenced are gaining
back their voices and indeed in 2011 on
the 100th anniversary of the women's
History Month President Barack Obama
said that there is still work to be done
before women achieve true
parody but what is
parody is it the equal opportunity to
speak up for yourself your safety your
emotional needs or is parody the erasing
of women women's spaces women's sports
and women's
voices women thought that the kind thing
to do was to make space and hold their
tongues but rather than finding a
tolerable compromise they were pushed
another foot for every inch they gave
they had to violate their boundaries and
yield to men in their self-esteem while
forsaking their own women were on a path
to become history not to make
history 14 14 years ago women Across the
Nation let the women working in garment
shops know they were not alone that they
need not be silent that they need not
accept danger just to make men more
comfortable we have a choice to make our
children and grandchildren are watching
suspend to come and
somebody needs to come down and withdraw
silenced needs
do I object and I withdraw my consent
representative Murray withdraws her
consent representative Murray withdraws
her consent so the question now is shall
the M Contin the question is shall the
the me Members members take your seats
vote request for the request is for a
roll call it is sufficiently seconded
for
the motion before us is withdrawing
consent for representative Lon to
continue speaking
vote chair recognizes representative Jam
for a parliamentary
inquiring thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that I've been teaching women's history
at the college level for more than 20
years and if I believe that we do not
need to denigrate or diminish any of our
fellow granted Staters in order to
celebrate and honor women's history when
I now press the red butt
end chair recognizes representative Lon
for a parliamentary
inor Mr Speaker if I know that this vote
is whether or not we are going to
silence women would I then press the red
[Applause]
can we at least have order for a few
more
minutes the motion before us is to
whether representative Lon can continue
speaking this is a uh vote has to be
three 3- fifths this is a 3- fifth
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
while members present had an opportunity
the house will be in order damn
it
speak thank you Mr Speaker as I was
saying the women working in the GU guide
garment shops were placed in danger by
The Men Who owned and operated those
garment
shops now we have a choice to make our
children and Grand children are watching
they're dying because of you will we
stand with these wom the house will be
in
order will we stand with these women and
girls who are reclaiming their voices
reclaiming their spaces and reclaiming
their right to succeed or fail on their
own merits or will we roll over and make
this the
first rules will we then will we instead
roll over and make this the first women
R History
Month I ask you to stand with me with
the president who just signed a
proclamation declaring March 2025
women's history month for women's rights
to tell women and girls that they matter
that their voices matter and that their
boundaries matter we must overcome the
campaign to silence women or women
ourselves will become history
[Applause]
thank you Mr Speaker and I look forward
to the day we can when we can also
celebrate men who have been demonized
and villainized for too long
[Applause]
newel thank you Mr
Speaker each year on March
6th we who have lost a loved one to
overdose make our presence our grief and
our love with nowhere to
this tradition resonates deeply with me
personally as my kids often wrote
messages on
balloons to send up to Daddy on his
birthday when they were
young I won't hold you for
long but I felt it was important to mark
this day particularly in this
body and to harden our resolve in taking
the necessary steps to prevent further
loss if you are willing and able
I ask you to stand for a moment of
silence to remember those lost and the
many Granite Staters who live on without
parents grandparents siblings children
and
you jerich and I representative
Gallagher
hello um I rise today in commemoration
of the European day of remembrance for
the righteous um it which is today March
6 um so i' I'd just like to read the
resolution for it it's short
um the European Parliament having regard
to rule 123 of its rules of procedure
recalling a great moral significance of
the garden of the rightous in Jerusalem
initiated by the late mosha bki paying
tribute to those who helped the Jews
during the Holocaust recalling the
institutions that have honored people
who saved lives during all genocides and
mass murders such as the Armenian
Bosnian Cambodian and Rwandan ones and
all other crimes against Humanities per
perpetrated in the 20th and 21st
centuries recalling all those who
preserved human dignity during Nazism
and communist
totalitarianism whereas the remembrance
of good is essential to the process of
European integration because it teaches
younger Generations that everyone can
always choose to help other human beings
and defend human dignity and the public
institutions have a duty to highlight
the example set by people who manage to
protect those persecuted out of
hate uh therefore supports the call made
by Leading citizens to establish a
European day of re remembrance for the
righteous to commemorate on the 6th of
March those who challenged crimes
against humanity and
totalitarianism with individual
responsibility
um so I I think that's important for us
to remember now
um
especially as our
alliances with Europe are being
threatened um I think we need to
remember some of our shared values of
standing up against oppression and
totalitar
arianism and I hope that you will do
that with me today
[Applause]
thanks for what reason does a member
rise to make a motion State your motion
I move that all of the unanimous consent
remarks that we just heard be placed in
the permanent
journal without
we representative Osborne moves the
house stand and recess for the purposes
of introduction of bills vacate motions
enroll Bill amendments enroll Bill
reports and receiving messages are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say
I all those opposed say nay the eyes
have it and the motion is adopted house
is in recess until Thursday March 13th